Moin Leute, 2,5 Wochen, noch 2 bis 2,5 Wochen, dann habe ich meinen letzten Arbeitstag,
ich bin echt aufgeregt, wie das weiter geht, ich mein, ich weiß wie es weiter geht, aber
was dann so passiert, ich bin wahrscheinlich erstmal komplett verwirrt, so, weil ich jetzt
seit über 10 Jahren nicht mehr da hingehe, gut, ich mein, so großartig, weit weg voneinander
ist das ganze ja nicht, also zwischen aktuellem Arbeitgeber und neuem liegen ja irgendwie
so 800 Meter Luftlinie oder sowas, alles jetzt nicht so große Umgewöhnung, nur dass der
neue eine ordentliche Homeoffice-Regelung hat und nicht so dieses Jahr 50% Anwesenheit
und ihr könnt ja froh sein, dass wir so geil sind und mehr gibt es auch nicht, so sieht
es aus, bevor der Stream wirklich losgeht, will ich gerade nochmal schnell eine Sache
gucken, also wenn das immer einmal die Woche machen, kurz den GitHub Trends reingucken,
letztes hat hier irgendjemand eine Seite geschickt, wo man am besten, wo man wohl noch besser
Trends sieht oder sowas, aber gucken wir mal, was gibt es denn hier, This Week, was ist
was Trended, lass mich ran, Krypto und AI-Stalls, Self-Hosted Memo, was soll ich mir da drunter
vorstellen, irgendwie so eine weitere Notiz-Anwendung oder sowas in der Richtung, ok, oh, aha, na gut,
Chat-GPT, ja was sonst, China-Chinesen-Chat-GPT, komische Programmiersprache, wo ich keine
Ahnung, wozu man sie verwendet, Rust-Game-Engine, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, wahrscheinlich AI, AI,
AI, AI, AI, nee, nee, irgendwas anderes, Datenbank, ein neues JavaScript-Framework,
was auch sonst, AI, Peißen-Stalls, AI, AI, AI, ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich
auch AI, AI, natürlich, was sonst, AI, was ist das, Coolify, ok, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was Coolify sein soll, was ist Coolify, made-self-hosting-simple, ok, irgendein Dashboard oder sowas,
resolviert Producer, die Wochenbremse, auch, das würde ich nicht gut für einen
und du kriegst noch mehr Sterne.
Ich mein, 420 Stars ist natürlich schon extrem pog.
Das ist quasi, das ist ja quasi das Gegenstück zu Viewbotting, Github, Githubs, wobei es
ja keine, wobei es ja keine Bots sind, die echte Leute.
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Du musst gerade mal alles zumachen.
All 2 Kekke.
Ok, mal alles schließen.
Ah, Kekona, hell yeah.
Auf Github mit Klarnamen.
Painschamp.
Was hast du gemacht, dass es nicht laggt, wenn man Enter drückt?
Es gibt 2 Varianten, wenn man Enter drückt.
Es gibt 2 Varianten, warum es laggt.
Also wenn man einfach nur normal Enter drückt, mit der Default-Config passiert nichts.
Aber sobald du ein Farbschema eingestellt hast, wovon ich mal ausgehe, dass du das gemacht
hast, und die aktuellste Version benutzt, die im Repo ist, dann laggt es, weil es irgendwie
Probleme gibt beim Einlesen des Farbschemas, was du machen kannst ist, entweder das Farbschema
komplett selbst definieren, so wie ich das gemacht habe, was ich aber eh weiterhin so
machen werde, weil, Moment, wo ist hier meine Config, da, weil ich die Standard Farbschema
als alle nicht so tolle finde, also du kannst den Kram hier selbst, Colors, selbst definieren,
dann laggt es nicht, oder du verwendest die neue Git-Version, also du installierst nicht
Westterm, sondern du installierst Westterm Git, da ist das Problem auch schon behoben.
Aber ich habe so die Farben definiert und keinen Farbschema gesetzt, weil ich das so
schöner finde und es nicht laggt.
Das ist natürlich doof, wenn das nicht geht, tja, ganze Nix posten, ich kann noch mal eine
andere Sache gucken, hat das letztens einer gepostet, dass man hier angeblich viel besser
die Trends sieht, Infinite Storage Clitch, ja, Moment, nicht Monthly, Weekly, Jet, okay,
League of, Moment, League of Legends Hack Script More Functionality, alles klar, Genshin Hack,
jetzt geht's, der ESP, Moment, Moment, ist das, ist das ein ferngesteuerter ESP32 der
USB Input simuliert, oder was ist das, nee, nee, ach nee, hier, das hat mit dem Microcontroller
nix zu tun, okay, Genshin, Genshin Sheets, alles klar, Sea of Thieves Hack, warum trendet
das alles, Mann, Rust Hack, Aimbot, Daisy, na gut, der Kram scheint beliebt zu sein,
ja, Warzone 2 Hack, No Recoil, alles klar, der Typ ist aber ganz schön, da trendet ja
nur Scam Zeug, oder was heißt Scam Zeug, nur zweifelhaftes Shady Zeug, also ich weiß
ja nicht, CSS Reset for TypeScript, okay, die Frontend Welt ist echt abgedreht, aber
was soll mir das sagen, CSS Reset for TypeScript, CSS Reset ist doch irgendwie so ein Spacer
Element, oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, wo du dann, wo du dann irgendwie die CSS Vererbung
austrickst, ja, was hat das mit TypeScript zu tun, okay, keine Ahnung, das ist anhand
der Beschreibung Checking nicht was es sein soll, AI, AI, übrigens, jetzt wissen wir
warum dieser Shit in der offiziellen, in der offiziellen GitHub Geschichte nicht auftaucht,
weil, dass irgendjemand gebotet hat alles auf 120 Sterne, oder anders kann ich mir nicht
erinnern, meine es ist doch doch relativ Nische, irgendwelche grossen Hacks auf GitHub, wie
lebt Fortnite noch hier so offensichtlich, wie Fortnite lebt, weil es viele Leute spielen,
das ist eines der gehypesten Games der letzten Jahre gewesen, das hat sicherlich immer noch
Millionen Spieler, ich meine das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr so mega gehypt wie vor
3 Jahren, vor 3, 4 Jahren, aber immer noch, lohnt sich das, ja ich glaube das haben wir
sogar offen, irgendwo haben wir das offen, guck mal, ja, da, eine Milliarde Bits teilschön
Poggers, Account Name lässt sich auch, achso mein, das hatten wir ja schon, ja, ansonsten
gab es die Woche irgendwas, irgendwas spannendes, heute bin ich echt noch so ein bisschen,
da sieht man mal wieder, wie verkackt Windows ist, bisher ging die Sache immer auf, aber
jetzt muss ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf einmal wieder sagen, ja ich möchte das
in Fotos öffnen, ok, ja, ich glaube das haben wir AI ausschneiden lassen, ja natürlich
wird es auch weiterhin sein, das ist ja auch eine Sache, da lag ich komplett falsch, ohne
Mist, ich hab damals, als so der riesen Minecraft Hype war, hab ich mir so gedacht, ja ich verstehe
warum die Leute den Content gucken, aber irgendwann wird das auch mal langweilig, aber nee, Minecraft
ist strong seit irgendwie 10 Jahren oder so, durchgängig auf YouTube, das hätte ich am
Anfang auch nicht gedacht, der neue Ryzen, ja das hab ich gelesen, aber das hat mich
jetzt nicht so groß gejuckt, ansonsten war die Woche glaube ich gar nicht so viel spannendes,
das ist irgendwo ein ordentliches Weekly Summary, irgendwie so ein, kennt jemand ein ordentliches
IT News Weekly Summary, ich hab früher ganz gerne die Hacker News Zusammenfassungen gelesen,
aber die gibt es nicht mehr, Heise hatte sowas auch mal, aber bei Heise findest du ja prinzipiell
irgendwie nix mehr, wenn du in der Suche suchst, du musst keine Weekly Zusammenfassungen angucken,
ansonsten ist glaube ich nicht so spannendes gewesen, passiert ja auch nicht jede Woche
irgendwas spannendes, auf GitHub haben wir gesehen, ist wieder alles voller AI und diesmal
kein Kryptogramm, aber immer noch 90% AI Projekte, ich glaube das wird auch in nächster Zeit erstmal
so weitergehen, ja ich glaub so ein spannendes gibt es da grad nicht, naja, ich muss nächste
Woche auf jeden Fall erstmal alles so vorbereiten, dass ich da mich vom Acker machen kann, ich
muss meinen Schrank leer räumen, ich muss meine ganzen, mein Notebook, zumindest das
eine Notebook mal formatieren und abgeben, bisschen Zeug aufräumen, noch ein paar Geschichten
bei GitHub hochladen, dass es noch verfügbar ist, wenn ich weg bin, also die nächsten zwei
Wochen werde ich mich darum kümmern, dass ich mich vom Acker mache dort, also ich großartig
großartig was arbeite, ehrlich gesagt, Mathe studieren so hart ist es wirklich, aber nicht
jetzt direkt, ich muss ja ehrlich sagen, das war krasser als ich mir das vorgestellt habe,
ich hab ja im Dezember meine Kündigung abgegeben und ich dachte mir so, ja gut man das sind
jetzt ja noch quasi drei Monate hin und das mach ich dann ganz normal weiter, aber womit
ich nicht gerechnet hab ist, dass meine Motivation, die eh schon, ich mein hatte ja einen Grund
warum ich da gekündigt hab, die jetzt eh schon nicht in höheren Sphären war, also ich
war jetzt vorher auch schon nicht so wahnsinnig motiviert, aber seitdem ich die Kündigung
abgegeben hab, mich hat ja gar nichts mehr interessiert, am ersten Tag wo ich angefangen
hab, hab ich es erst richtig gemerkt, mich hat nichts interessiert, mich hat nicht interessiert,
was im Dezember gewesen ist, was im Dezember kaputt gegangen ist, vielleicht wo ich nicht
da war, mich hat noch nicht interessiert, was gerade gebaut, mich hat einfach nichts interessiert,
ich hab mir gedacht, okay, ich sitze jetzt einfach noch mal drei Monate meine Zeit ab
und gut ist, ich hab gefühlt drei Monate so gut wie nichts gemacht, außer ein paar Sachen
übergeben, soweit wie ging und ansonsten, ansonsten hab ich übelst rumgegammelt.
Was ist MRSK, MRSK, Deploy, ich kenne, ich kenne so Krankenhauskeime, die heißen so ähnlich,
Deploy, okay, das kenne ich noch nicht, was ist das, irgendwas mit 2,9 Sterne, lass mich
raten, ein neues JavaScript Framework, MRSK deploys webapps anywhere from bare metal to
cloud or it uses the dynamic transport traffic, okay, das ist Ruby, Leute, jemand der mal
wieder was in Ruby programmiert, ein Moment, ein Projekt das trendet in Ruby, das hab ich
ja schon seit den letzten acht Jahren oder so nicht mehr gesehen, Ruby, achso, ja dann
wunderts mich auch nicht, wenn er das ist, das ist der Ruby on Rails Erfinder, dass der
was in Ruby macht, okay, das verstehe ich ja noch, okay, alles klar.
Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, okay, ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht
so genau was es sein soll auf den ersten Blick, was ist das für eine Webseite, Moment, das
ist die REAPME ohne CSS dabei, okay, keine Ahnung was es sein soll, ich kopier mir das
erst mal raus, guck mir das irgendwann offstream an, man kann es zumindest schon mal nicht
aussprechen, MRSK, und mit was deploysst du so MRSK, aber auf den zweiten oder dritten
Blick fragst du dich warum es die Lösung braucht, es kann schon sein, ich hab's jetzt
erstmal nicht gecheckt was da der Sinn von ist, ich mein, irgendwelche Containersachen
zu deployen, da gibt's ja schon Deploy-Yammel, so heißt das in der Kubernetes auch, also
Deployment, vielleicht nennt man das die Datei dann so, aber naja, gut, was auch immer, aber
es trendet auf GitHub, also müsst es viele Leute geil finden, der CSS ist bloat, braucht
man nicht, wenn man Text fett machen will, kann man den auch in Bolt-Text setzen, CSS
ist overrated, man kann auch einfach Table-Layouts machen anstatt CSS, easy, falls sich noch irgendjemand
dran erinnert, wie man früher Webseiten-Layouts gemacht hat mit Tabellen, schade, dass Ruby,
ja, die Sprache kriegt ja immer noch regelmäßig Updates und kriegt auch regelmäßig Verbesserungen,
letzte Ruby Version hat zum Beispiel richtig was an der Performance gedreht, also das
neue Ruby ist jetzt irgendwie dreimal schneller als die Version davor, Ruby ist ne Supersprache,
also ich kann mich echt, ich erinnere mich gerne ans Ruby programmieren und ich würde
heute auch die ein oder anderen Sachen in Ruby machen, das Problem ist halt ähnlich
das was du gesagt hast, dass das ganze Ruby Ökosystem so ein bisschen eingeschlafen ist
und dass Ruby jetzt auch nicht so diesen breiten Zuspruch mehr hat, also da hat Pysons schon
gewonnen, die haben ja mal ne Zeit lang so ein bisschen competed was so dynamische Sprachen
angeht, Pysons und Ruby, da gab es die einen die fanden Pysons besser und die anderen fanden
Ruby geiler, dann gab es irgendwann am Anfang dieser Geschichte Ruby on Rails und da war
Ruby halt mega gehypt, jeder hat was in Ruby gemacht und es hat keinen so wirklich drumherum
mehr interessiert, alles ist auf den Ruby Zug aufgesprungen, aber durch andere Web Frameworks
und dass Ruby on Rails immer mehr an Bedeutung verloren hat, ist dann halt auch Ruby wieder
ein bisschen mit abgestiegen und bei Ruby ne Supersprache, also ich finde Ruby immer
noch sehr Pong, ja und heute auch die letzten paar Jahre schon, gerade im so wissenschaftlichen
Umfeld und jetzt was Machine Learning angeht, da ist da ist Python besonders besonders gefragt
gerade, ja Ruby ist wirklich ne gute Sprache und vieles was heute so verbreitet ist und
Standard muss man sagen kommt auch aus der Ruby Welt, ja guckt euch mal zum Beispiel
C-Sharp, Moment, guckt euch mal so nen C-Sharp Minimal API Example an, falls die Micro, alter
Microsoft, hier guck so sieht ein Minimal Hello World API in C-Sharp aus, so und jetzt gucken
wir uns mal an Express Minimal Example so, Hello World Express sieht, boah fuck alter
mein Auge, ihr seht sieht fast genauso aus und wisst ihr woher das kommt, das, ups, das
wollte ich gerade anklicken, das kommt alles von diesem Ruby Web Server oder von dieser
Ruby Library, guck mal fast schon ein bisschen gebated im Hintergrund, das kommt alles von
dieser Ruby Library, das war so eines der ersten Minimal Web Frameworks die es gegeben
hat, Paul langisch für den Sub, also ich finde schon dass man, dass man das schon gut
sieht wer da wen inspiriert hat, ja, das war so eines der ersten Minimal Web Frameworks
die es so gegeben hat, das war damals auch sehr beliebt, ne weitere Sache wo Ruby auch
großen Einfluss drauf hatte ist AirSpec, AirSpec ist ein Test Framework für Ruby und so diese
Benamung von vielen Dingern und wie Tests aufgebaut sind und so dieses it expects contains
bla bla bla, da kommt vieles auch von AirSpec, ich meine es gibt es heute in fast jeder Sprache
Testing Frameworks die so ähnlich wie AirSpec aufgebaut sind, ich würde sagen fast in jeder
Sprache, das AirSpec Buch habe ich übrigens auch, irgendwo hier noch rumstehen, also Ruby
hatte schon, mein Rails ist auch klar, Rails hat vieles inspiriert was Web Frameworks angeht,
also da sieht man schon Ruby hat schon einigen Einfluss drauf gehabt, wir können ja mal
kurz auf GitHub gerade, nicht den Fiatchamp, da werde ich nur wieder dran erinnern dass
ich da was machen muss, wir gehen einfach mal hier auf alle Projekte und suchen mal Ruby
und dann sortiert nach Sternen, das ergibt keinen Sinn, Rails hat definitiv mehr Sterne,
kann es sein dass die GitHub Suche einfach wieder sackt, ja weil Rails hat 52.000 Sterne
und ich hauptsächlich in Ruby programmiert, warum sackt die GitHub Suche wieder, was ist
da los, ok dann nehmen wir mal dieses komische an, trending Ruby, nicht weekly, yearly, overall
vielleicht, da sieht man mal, jährlich trendende Ruby Projekte 875 Sterne ist eigentlich, ok
die GitHub Suche ist mal wieder absolut, absolut shit was das angeht, sonst hätte man jetzt
wirklich ein paar Projekte sehen können, die in Ruby programmiert sind und die auch Einfluss
hatten auf das gesamte, Gesamtkonstrukt was es an Frameworks in allen möglichen Sprachen
gibt, also Ruby hat da schon einen gewissen Einfluss drauf gehabt, Onopole und Paul danke
für den Sub, Ruby ist, ja genau ganz bestimmt, es gibt ja zig Projekte dafür, gibt es ja
zig zig Projekte von Sachen die Python nach C++ und dann compilen und da gibt es mal mehr
und mal weniger Probleme mit, ja aber man muss halt sagen nach aktuellen Gesichtspunkten
ist Python auf jeden Fall die Sprache die zur Zeit deutlich, deutlich mehr verwendet
wird, als Ruby allerdings das kann sich auch wieder ändern, sollte mal wieder irgendeine
super tolle neue Hype Technologie rauskommen und das hauptsächlich in Ruby, dann ist auch
Ruby wieder angesagt, ich würde es mir wünschen weil Ruby an sich eine super Sprache ist,
deswegen ist es noch in Ruby, viele Startups damals haben in Rails angefangen, Twitter
glaube ich auch, mittlerweile ist Twitter ja auf irgendeiner komischen Java basierten
Geschichte, Twitter, Github, Github, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob Github immer noch
eine Rails Anwendung intern ist, wahrscheinlich mittlerweile nicht mehr, aber Github war auch
lange Zeit eine Ruby Anwendung, fallen einem wahrscheinlich noch mehr ein wenn man ein
bisschen nachdenkt, aber viele heute sehr große bekannten Seiten haben als Ruby on Rails,
als Ruby on Rails wie haben sie damals gesagt als Ruby on Rails Shop angefangen, gibt bestimmt
noch deutlich mehr, mittlerweile sind die natürlich da ein bisschen rausgewachsen und ich weiß
gar nicht ob bekannt ist mittlerweile, wie Github intern läuft, also GitLab war am Anfang
auch mal Ruby on Rails, ich weiß nicht wie es da aussieht, wahrscheinlich ist es immer
noch Ruby, konnte ich mir vorstellen, weil das schreibst du nicht einfach mal komplett
um, heute hättest du halt mehr Möglichkeiten gehabt, damals hattest du halt so zu dieser
Ruby on Rails Hochzeit, so 2004 bis 2009 oder so, ja so 2004 bis 2009 und 2010 vielleicht
noch, da Ruby on Rails voll angesagt war diese 5 Jahre, da hat es so vieles was mit Ruby
on Rails gestartet ist, heute, und du hattest halt auch nicht so viel Auswahl, heute würden
diese Projekte wahrscheinlich alle was anderes nehmen, gerade GitLab würde wahrscheinlich
heute nicht mehr als Ruby on Rails Anwendung anfangen, sondern wahrscheinlich auch nicht
als Node Shares, wahrscheinlich würden die das heute in Go oder so machen, aber damals
hattest du nicht so viel Auswahl wenn du gut funktionierendes einfaches highly productive
was auch immer Web Framework haben wolltest, da gab es Rails, die Alternative zur damaligen
Zeit war sowas wie PAP, genau wollte ich gerade sagen, damalig war die Alternative, wobei
es damals auch so Sachen wie Laravel und sowas für PAP noch nicht gab, gerade Laravel ist
auch sehr stark inspiriert von Ruby on Rails, also erkennt man viele Parallelen dazwischen,
ja und viele andere Web Frameworks sind da schon maßgeblich mit inspiriert worden,
ja so siehts aus, und Opal Möb, danke für den Sub, ja ich hätte, ich fänds cool wenn
Ruby mal wieder ein bisschen Aufwind hätte, wenn Rails mal wieder ein bisschen, wenn er
ein bisschen dazu fährt, so aus Drehenge, Hydrated Stain, für vieles ist PAP auch ausreichend,
ja ich mein guckt euch mal an, ich glaub Facebook ist immer noch PAP oder MySQL, PAP und MySQL,
ne intern ist Facebook wahrscheinlich auch vieles mittlerweile ersetzt worden, aber ich
glaub angefangen haben die auch als PAP Seite, ja also viele Web Seiten sind ja heute noch
auf PAP Basis, ja und viele Web Seiten haben heute immer noch im Frontend jQuery am Start,
darf man sagen, sollte man gar nicht unterschätzen, ich glaube jQuery ist immer noch, wenns rein
um Verbreitung angeht, also auf welchen Web Seiten das eingesetzt wird, vor allem weil
es halt oftmals auch irgendwo noch als Dependency mitkommt, ist jQuery glaub ich immer noch
auch 2023 das verbreitetste JavaScript Framework was es gibt, niemand macht mir wirklich absichtlich
freiwillig was in jQuery, aber ich glaube irgendwie 60 oder 70% oder so sind total viele
der Top Web Seiten der Welt haben irgendwie jQuery, ja Facebook hat viel Gedöns, ich
mein Google ja auch, Google kommt jetzt mit ihrem komischen C++, eigenen C++ abklatscht
um die Ecke wo ich nicht sehe, dass das irgendwie großartig erfolgreich sein wird, was macht
das eigentlich gerade auf GitHub, ja dass es viele Sterne hat heißt ja noch erstmal nichts,
viele Google Projekte die neu mit Hype gelauncht werden haben, ja also ich muss sagen ich find
die Syntax äußerst pepega von Carbon, das ist so ein bisschen als hätt man C++ und
Rust zusammen gewurstet, ja also ich glaub auch nicht, dass es großartig erfolgreich
sein wird auf Dauer, vielleicht entweder Google, hast du ein privates LinkedIn Profil,
ja, ah nee nicht GitHub, äh LinkedIn, ja, nee hab ich nicht, das ist nicht mein LinkedIn
Profil, da hab ich sogar das Passport zu verloren, das hab ich nur mal als Gag für ein Video
angelegt, ich hab hier keinerlei Recovery Möglichkeit für den Account mehr, nee ich hab kein privates
GitHub Profil, Kollege von mir, oh nein, pepehands, äh Kollege mit dem ich jetzt auch den Arbeitgeber
wechsle, der kommt ja mit, der hat nen LinkedIn Profil und der meinte auch da bist du ziemlich
zugespammt, das meiste ist allerdings Müll, rechts gab es noch einen Peter Agiling, tatsächlich,
ein Coach bei Google, ich glaubs ja nicht, also wie gesagt, der meint da gibt es jede
Menge Zeug und das meiste ist Müll, wahrscheinlich, also wenn man zu wenig Anfragen bekommt,
man möchte mehr Anfragen, muss man wahrscheinlich sein Profil ein bisschen tunen und da so ein
paar Buzzwords reinschreiben, Def, Sack, Ops, Def, Buss, Sack, Ops, Puls, Sack, Def, Buss,
Sack, Sack, Ops, Puls, Sack, Cloud, Native, Solution, Engineer, Officer oder irgendwie
sowas oder kommen sie alle angerückt und sagen hey willst du nicht zu uns, du bist ja so ein
geiler Dude, wir wollen dich haben, dann wirst du gescampt von irgendwelchen Leuten, die
dich vermitteln wollen und sich das meiste selbst einstecken, also ich glaube zu 95%
kann man diese ganzen Sachen auf LinkedIn knicken, umso höheren sagen, selbst hab ich
keinen LinkedIn Account und ich mach mir wahrscheinlich auch keinen LinkedIn Account, wenn es nicht
unbedingt sein muss.
Ich hab jetzt relativ easy so einen neuen Job gefunden, relativ easy war es ja, ging
ja schnell und wozu brauch ich dein LinkedIn Profil?
Mit den paar Leuten, wo ich mich gut verstehe, kann ich auch ohne LinkedIn in Kontakt stayen,
da brauch ich kein LinkedIn für, ja, also sollte ich vielleicht nochmal in nächster
Zeit den Job wechseln, was ich nicht glaube, weil aktuell sieht das alles sehr nice aus
bis jetzt und die Bezahlung ist auch nice, also insofern sehe ich da erstmal gar keine
Veranlassung dazu, dreck, so lang schon für den Sub, aber man weiß ja nie, vielleicht
gibt es ja irgendwie doch Sachen, wenn man das dann intern kennt, die einem so auf den
Back gehen, dass man da keinen Bock drauf hat, aber ich glaub's ja nicht aktuell, wäre
ja auch doof, hätte ja auch keinen Bock drauf, weil so Job suchen ist trotzdem immer irgendwie
mit Stress, bisschen Ungewissheit und sich Gedanken machen verbunden und da hab ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Die Zeit verwende ich lieber auf Streamen, YouTube und Sachen, wo ich Bock hab, MMO-Kreisel
grind, anstatt mir um irgendwelche real life jobtechnischen Geschichten Gedanken machen
zu müssen.
Deswegen kann ich es auch jedem nur empfehlen, wo wir gerade dabei sind, wenn ihr genug verdient
und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass viele von uns hier im Chat, in der IT-Arbeit und ganz
gut über die Runden kommen mit ihrem Gehalt, wenn ihr euch das leisten könnt, kann sich
ja jeder überlegen, manche können es, manche können es nicht, gerade wenn man jemand bei
mir auf der Arbeit zum Beispiel weiß, der könnte sich Teilzeit nicht leisten, der muss
ein Haus abbezahlen und so, ist ja alles was anderes, aber wenn ihr es euch leisten könnt,
dann überlegt, ob ihr nicht Teilzeit arbeitet.
Es reicht schon einen Tag, einen Tag weniger, das ist wirklich das Beste, was man machen
kann.
Das ist viel entspannter einfach die ganze Woche und das, obwohl es nur einen Tag mehr
frei ist, wenn man das so legt, dass es quasi zum Wochenende dazu zählt, also bei mir ist
ja quasi dann Samstag, Sonntag, Montag, wo ich frei hab, das ist zwar nur ein Tag mehr,
aber das kommt einem viel länger vor als nur ein Tag, weil man darf eine Sache nicht vergessen,
es ist ein Tag mehr Wochenende, aber es ist zeitgleich auch ein Tag weniger Arbeiten,
das heißt ihr habt einen Tag mehr Wochenende und gleichermaßen einen Tag weniger Arbeiten,
also dieses Wochenende ist es auch schneller wieder da, das macht echt einen riesen Unterschied,
was employee claims she can't, I can't, she can't use Microsoft Windows for religious
reasons, IT to provide laptop with Linux, ja das ist eine gute Sache, sonst sollten mehr
machen.
Tja, ich finde das sinnvoll.
Freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl sollte es eh überall geben.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich gezwungen werde, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber Windows
zu benutzen.
Ich meine, Windows-only auf keinen Fall, weil es gibt ja Linux-Server und WSL und alles,
aber kann ja sein, dass die Windows auf dem Laptop haben wollen.
Vielleicht gibt es aber eine Möglichkeit mit einer VM und...
...ja, mal gucken.
Wenn es um die Sicherheit geht, dann sollten sie eher alle Linux verwenden als Windows,
oder?
Wir hatten also, wir hatten einen großen, ich kann es wie gesagt im Detail nicht erzählen
und Namen nennen kann ich auch nicht, aber wir hatten einen großen Security-Unfall in
den 10 Jahren, wo ich dort bin, wo ich aktuell arbeite.
So richtig gegen die Wand gefahren.
Da wurden dann auch Daten verschlüsselt auf einem File-Server und solche Geschichten.
Da waren die Hacker-Mans am Start und wie kam das?
Wie kam das?
Es kam daher, jetzt haltet euch mal fest, es kam daher, weil, nee, mit E-Mail, mit E-Mail
hatten wir auch mal was, aber das meine ich nicht.
Nee, nee Leute, nein, nein, nein, nein, also E-Mail hatten wir auch mal was, aber das meine
ich nicht.
Social-Problem, nee auch nicht, also folgendermaßen war das, ein Dienstleister von uns hat sich
Malware und Zeug eingefangen, jetzt mal um die kurze Variante zu machen, ein Dienstleister
und dieser Dienstleister liefert bei uns Dinge ein und zwar über einen SFTP-Server oder
sowas und diese SFTP-Server lief nicht unter Linux, sondern unter Windows und ich krieg
es nicht mal hundertprozentig zusammen, zumindest war das, glaube ich, irgendeine uralte Version
und du konntest aus dem SFTP-Server relativ easy ausbrechen und dann weiß ich nicht mal
genau wie es weiterging, zumindest war es relativ easy an einen Admin-Account zu kommen,
ich krieg es gar nicht mal genau zusammen, also zumindest sind die irgendwie an einen
Admin-Account gekommen und dann war, also das war richtig verkackt, richtig Windows-Geschiss,
ich krieg es gar nicht mal richtig zusammen, richtiges, richtiger Windows-Shit war das
wieder, den haben sie übrigens mittlerweile erwischt sogar, die Angreifer, aber wie es
da rechtlich weitergegangen ist weiß ich nicht, bestimmt in irgendeinem Request im Klartext
mitgeschickt, nee, nee, nee, nee, das war, ich muss mir da echt mal ein bisschen Gedanken
drüber machen, wie es genau war, die waren auf dieser einen Windows-Kiste, ich weiß es
nicht mehr, entweder war diese Windows-Kiste auch Domain-Controller oder sie haben easy
irgendwie einen Admin-Account gekriegt, ich weiß nicht mal wie und dann konnten sie noch
mehr Zeug herumsauen, da hatten wir dann auch verschlüsselte Dateien auf dem File-Server
und sowas, aber wisst ihr was das witzige war, bei diesem ganzen Security-Vorfall, überall
hatten sie Bedenken, also alle Windows-Server wurden überprüft, wurden teils neu aufgebaut,
und es gab die Order, dass kein Mitarbeiter mehr sein Windows-Notebook benutzen darf,
bis das geklärt ist, weil über die Software-Verteilung wohl Keylogger und Speicherauslesetools verteilt
wurden, also sie haben Zugriff bekommen über den Admin-Account auf die Software-Verteilung
und haben dann auf jedes Mitarbeiter-Notebook Keylogger und Ram-Auswertungs-Dinger kopiert
und da war das Problem, dass manche Leute Keypass und Passwort-Manager benutzt haben
und aufgefallen, ach ja wisst ihr eigentlich wie das ganze aufgefallen ist, jetzt weiß
ich es wieder, wisst ihr wie das ganze aufgefallen ist, weil jemand auf dem File-Server, also
passt mal auf, halte euch mal fest, aufgefallen ist das ganze deswegen, weil einer auf einem
File-Server im Klartext einen Dampf von einer Keypass-Datei gefunden hat, also die hatten
wohl irgendwie so ein Ram-Auslesetool auf manche Notebooks drauf und wenn du da Keypass
geöffnet hast, wurde quasi die Keypass-Datenbank gedammt auf irgendeinem Windows-Share, wahrscheinlich
wollten sie es von da abgreifen und irgendjemand hat das gefunden, irgendjemand hat die Keypass-Sachen
im Klartext auf dem File-Server gefunden und hat sich gedacht, Moment, da stimmt doch
irgendetwas nicht und so ist das aufgefallen, das ist glücklicherweise alles innerhalb
von ein paar Stunden aufgefallen, ja und wie gesagt es gab dann die Anweisung, niemand
darf mehr Windows verwenden, also keiner durfte an seinen Notebook dran und sowas und was
haben wir dann gemacht, wir waren die einzigen die was machen konnten, weil wir hatten ja
Linux Notebooks und unsere Server waren auch auf Linux Basis, das heißt wir hatten die
einzigen Systeme im gesamten Unternehmen, wo man sich eigentlich keine Gedanken machen
musste, dass dort irgendetwas drauf ist, ja musste von ausgehen, aber der Passwort-Manager-Schützer
war voll weniger, ja unterm Strich schon, ja ja das haben wir auch, ja mach, muss dich
nicht mehr festhalten, ja das war witzig, also wir hatten die einzigen Notebooks und
die einzigen Server, wo wir uns sicher waren, die sind nicht infiziert, weil halt ordentlich
Linux und abgesichert und es war sogar temporär so, dass Leute dann um arbeiten zu können
sich Ubuntu USB-Sticks haben anfertigen lassen, da sind dann teilweise Leute zu uns gekommen
haben gesagt, hier Max, ich hab nen USB-Stick, kannst du mir mal kurz Ubuntu oder sowas drauf
machen, haben den Leuten Ubuntu auf den USB-Stick gemacht, dann haben die dann unter Ubuntu
irgendwie so 2-3 Tage was gemacht, weil sie eben noch es nicht mehr verwenden durften,
dann wurden alle Notebooks platt gemacht, das war ein riesen Akt, dann wurden alle Notebooks
platt gemacht und dann gab es so ne neue, so ne neue Geräte-Ausgabe-Schalter, da musste
dann jeder hoch und witzigerweise wurden wir dann auch hoch zitiert, so nach dem Motto
holt euch ein neues Notebook ab, dann hab ich gesagt, Moment, unsere Notebooks sind gar
nicht betroffen und dann meinte der Typ so, doch doch, alle Notebooks sind betroffen
sind, nein, mein Notebook ist nicht betroffen, ja wir müssen das Notebook austauschen, guck
mal, das ist eines der wenigen Notebooks mit Linux, das ist nicht betroffen von eurem Windows-Shit
mann, lasst mich in Ruhe, AS400, gibt's das noch, das sind so fette IBM-Storage-Systeme,
wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf hab, ja, ach ne, sind das die Mainframe-Geschichten,
da hab ich durcheinander gebracht, ich dachte, die heißen iSeries, die Mainframe-Sachen,
oder ne, oder z, nicht i, z, ja, ach so, ja, ist jetzt, ist jetzt, ist jetzt AS400 ein
Storage-System oder ein Mainframe, ich bilde mir ein, das klingt wie ein Storage-System,
Mainframe, ok, ok, wir hatten mal eine AS9000 hatten wir mal, das war ein Storage-System,
obei, hieß das, hieß das Storage, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich unschlüssig,
ob das Ding wirklich AS9000 hieß, gab's sowas mal, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ne, dann weiß ich's nicht, ach, keine Ahnung, Mainframe, Mainframe-Shit, moin, Kusanus,
ich vermute mal, dass es nicht Kus-Anus ist, sondern Kusanus, Gachibas, ja, ja, wir brauchen
das ja auch für Banken-Zeug, ja, und eins ist klar, dieses Business-Enterprise-Zeug
an Hardware ist halt wieder unglaublich unsinnig teuer, naja, RS6000 kann auch sein, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
Ja, recuerde nicht auf jeden Fall Management-Made twitchですか?
haben und und die sterben wahrscheinlich demnächst auch aus ja so zeige mal her zeige mal her was
haben wir denn hier sonst noch nicht mario musik wir gucken jetzt mal ein bisschen was was was
können wir lassen mal gucken was können wir uns denn als erstes antun heute die welt ist abhängig
von dieser maschine ok werbung ne heute geht es um eine der wichtigsten maschinen der welt von
der du wahrscheinlich noch nie etwas gehört hast ok auf geht's dass wir uns mal lasst uns
das mal erklären ich hoffe es kommt jetzt nicht in bagger oder irgendwie sowas wie sieht das
thumbnail aus moment das muss ich mal thumbnail checken wait a minute nein warum warum lehten
das automatisch das soll nicht ich hatte mal firefox so eingestellt dass es kein autoplay
mehr macht hat jemand eine ahnung wie man autoplay ausschaltet in firefox keine ahnung
ich wollte mir nämlich das thumbnail angucken in groß die wichtigste maschine der welt für
alles klar plugin das mein firefox macht kein autoplay ok auf geht's heute geht es um eine
der wichtigsten maschinen der welt von der du wahrscheinlich noch nie gehört hast sie wurde
nur circa 140 mal verkauft und kostet pro stück ok wenn die nur 140 bevor er was sagt wenn
die nur 140 mal verkauft würde da wird die auch schweine teuer sein 100 millionen dollar es gibt
nur einen einzigen hersteller dieser maschine von dem alle länder weltweit abhängig sind
und die maschine in andere länder laut genug ja ich denke schon verschifft wird dann braucht man
dafür drei boeing 747 40 brachcontainer 20 lastwagen sie arbeitet so präzise dass sie
quasi vom mond aus mit einem laser eine münze auf der erde treffen könnte ich rede hier von
der maschine die es möglich macht die modernsten microchips der welt zu produzieren genau funktioniert
warum die ganze welt von ihr abhängig ist und was für konflikte dadurch drohen wenn es so 150
gibt und das alles wahrscheinlich vom gleichen hersteller dann verstehe ich warum es da konflikte
gibt damit willkommen bei brecken lab jacob hier los geht's microchips die bilden ja die
grundlage unserer modernen welt sie sind überall in unserem alltag zu finden in unseren autos
computer toast an unseren kühlschränken wie abhängig die produktionen sind das hat auch
die corona pandemie gezeigt weil dadurch lieferketten unterbrochen wurden und viele
unternehmen nicht an diese microchips haben konnten schätzungsweise zwei bis vier millionen autos
nicht gebaut werden viele leute vergeblich ja leute sekunde ich muss an der stelle mal kurz
pause machen autos nicht gebaut werden können es gibt gerade ihr wisst ja ich habe einen fiat 500
den habe ich letztes jahr im august gekauft und ich habe den als vorführe auto gekauft das heißt
ich wusste genau was drin ist und was nicht drin ist so und jetzt habe ich gelesen nachdem ich mal
ein bisschen rum geschaut habe wie es aktuell so aussieht bei fiat fiat verkackt es gerade so
was von extrem die liefern autos aus die nicht das enthalten was bestellt wurde zum beispiel du
hast dir das parkpaket gekauft und auf einmal ist keine rückfahrkamera oder keine rückfahrsensoren
dabei und fiat sagt dann so ja kann man auch nichts machen chipmangel was ist das denn für
eine ansage bitteschön du kannst doch nicht einfach in ein auto jemand bestellen lassen den das
parkpaket dabei bestellen lassen ihm das auto ausliefern und dann sagen ja ja gut wir hatten
halt chipmangel da fehlen jetzt halt ein paar essenzielle features aber ja du gibts nicht
anders was ist das denn für eine art und weise was wollen die einen wollen die die leute komplett
verarschen dass es nicht geht das chip chipmangel ist das musst du doch aber vorher sagen und nicht
kannst du nicht darauf hochen doch ist es ist es ich weiß nicht ob man das nicht so hart nennen
kann aber auf jeden fall ein mangel ja also du kannst auf jeden fall als kunde sagen nein das
ist nicht das was ich bestellt habe bitte nachbessern und wenn die das nicht können
kannst du dann theoretisch sogar ja wie heißt das das geld machen dass du dass es billiger
ist oder zurücktreten so was also auf sein lenkrad aber trotzdem also das kann es ja nicht sein vor
allem was ich richtig was ich richtig beschissen finde ist gar nicht mal so sehr dass sie das auto
dann eben so bauen wie es funktioniert sondern dass sie es im vorfeld den leuten nicht sagen
und die leute dann selbst gucken müssen enthält dieses auto alle 95 features diese enthalten
sollen und wenn nicht dann es nicht annehmen oder zum händler gehen zu sagen hier nachbessern das
ist doch für ein arsch mann du musst das im vorfeld kommunizieren muss sagen hey ihr auto
kann nicht gebaut werden mit rückfahrsensoren ich mein rückfahrsensor das ist doch mittlerweile
seit bestimmt zehn jahren standard in vielen bisschen teureren autos ich rede jetzt nicht
von der rückfahrkamera sondern von diesen piep piep piep dingern du du du du du dass
da halt weißt wie weit du von der wand oder vom nächsten auto oder so entfernt ist die
rückfahrsensoren haben die haben autos doch schon seit seit zehn jahren oder so und wenn du das
parkpaket bestellst ja guck mal was da für pakete gibt pakete ja zeig mal her was ist
mit der seite los das style paket ok ah die haben die pakete anscheinend auch auch umbenannt ok
wir machen jetzt also la prima ist die besser ausgestattete variant ikon ist die bisschen
weniger ausgestattete variant aber deutlich günstiger ich habe ein ikon an 4500 ikon allerdings mit zum
größten teil la prima ausstattung was total wirr ist weil du mein auto so wie es habe gar nicht
eins zu eins bestellen kannst das ist halt so ein vorführauto wo die halt die coolsten sachen vom
vom la prima dran gepappt haben dass die leute der ngora leises auto so du kannst du kannst das park
paket auswählen so zumindest ging das mal als man die bestellen kann mittlerweile haben sie
anscheinend wieder umgebaut hier config neuer 500 e
wählen elektrisch das da konfigurieren so und da kannst du auswählen hier neben pakete
komfortpaket tech paket so und da kann man ok das haben die jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen
anders gemacht so und da konnte da kann man auswählen ja ich will das mit kamera hat die rückfahrkamera
genau und park sensor genau das kannst du auswählen soll es gibt leute die haben diese kombination
ausgewählt also ok jetzt ist es das komfortpaket früher gab es auch noch das extra park paket
und sowas die haben diese kombination ausgewählt also park sensoren übrigens diese sachen mit 360
k drone view ist total hängen geblieben das sind stink normale park sensoren da ist das nix mit mit
mit kamera oder so das klingt total hängen geblieben das ist einfach park sensoren hinten ja so und
kamera so und jetzt gibt es leute die haben tatsächlich dieses komfortpaket bestellt und
wenn ihr auto ausgeliefert wird fehlt an die kamera oder es fehlt die rückfahrt sind rückfahrt sensoren
und sowas denkt man sich auch das kann doch nicht sein dass du das auf gut glück mitbekommen muss
dass an einem auto was fehlt und es im vorfeld keiner sagt also vier verkackt es gerade mega
bei der auslieferung von von 9 500 es ist jetzt weg
deswegen ich finde es tatsächlich sogar nach diesen gesichtspunkten besser man bestellt ihn
nicht neu sondern holt sich wirklich auch ein vorführauto oder irgendein auto wo man vorher
angucken kann selbst wenn es nicht 100 pro die ausstattung ist die man haben will zum beispiel
hätte ich sehr gerne noch eine teilbare rückenlehne gehabt die hat jetzt das auto nicht gehabt okay
ich meine ich habe es trotzdem genommen es wäre praktisch gewesen hätte es eine teilbare rückenlehne
gehabt weil das auto ist jetzt ja nicht das geräumigste und größte relativ klein sieht man
ja hier also nicht so kleine kugel ist das ja und zum beispiel wenn man einen weihnachtsbaum kauft
und will den weihnachtsbaum rein machen dann macht man halt hier hinten die rückbank könnte
man halt nur auf einer seite umklappen so dass man so dass man das hier irgendwie so durchlegen
kann also aber naja also man würde man würde dann die rückbank umklappen den sitz nach vorne
klappen und dann wird man dann hier den baum durchlegen und man selbst setzt sich dann da
hinten rein und der fahrer dahin und so was oder umgedreht man setzt sich hierhin und bei fahrer
dahinten das geht also nicht es ist auf jeden fall angenehmer wenn man die rückbank zusammen
umklappen kann kann man aber nicht bei meinem naja gut was ist das das sind 45 also ist das was ich
habe in ja zumindest wie gesagt guckt falls ihr so ein ding kauft fiat verkackt gerade richtig
aktuell die sind teuer ja das kommt ja noch dabei das kommt ja noch dabei die dinger sind teuer
und selbst dann schafft es fiat nichts die ordentlich auszuliefern das ist ja wirklich für
ein arsch ja du kriegst aktuell noch ein bisschen prämie du kriegst glaube ich noch 5000 euro prämie
wenn du ein elektroauto kaufst also wirst du dir neu ja das bezahlt ja das genau du wirst
irgendwie mit ordentlicher ausstattung wirst irgendwie 35k oder so rechnen müssen aber wenn
es so macht wie ich und dich mit einem zufrieden gibst der vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig genau
exakt das hat was du willst aber so ungefähr dann ist ich habe 25 ich habe irgendwie 25k oder
so bezahlt in dem dreh ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau ich habe es euch damals im stream
gesagt irgendwie irgendwie 25k so in dem dreh habe ich bezahlt
ja habe ich aber die prämie ist da schon drinne also du kriegst sie nicht noch mal die ist aber
schon eingerechnet
so also ich habe ich habe ich habe ungefähr 25k bezahlt
ja also ich hatte einen damit konnte man kurz nass putzen
das kommt drauf an also meistens kann das autohaus das für dich machen normalerweise
musst du das auto kaufen und dann kannst du das irgendwie einreichen beim bundesamt für
hast du nicht gesehen musste ich aber nicht machen weil das alles bei mir schon drinne war
also wie gesagt ich habe ein ich habe ein der als vorführe auto benutzt wurde dementsprechend
hatte der schon ein paar kilometer drauf keine ahnung mehr wie viel
und war deswegen halt schon ein bisschen gebraucht aber auch deutlich billiger ich meine zehntausend
euro billiger und keine wartezeit das kommt ja noch dabei und keine wartezeit ich habe
ihn zwar nicht hundertprozentig so bekommen wie ich ursprünglich wollte aber mehr oder weniger
jetzt gucken wir uns das video fertig an wie gesagt ich hatte ich hatte keine lieferzeit weil ich
schon einen genommen habe der so im autohaus stand ich bin probe gefahren mit dem auto und
während der probefahrt hat er gemeint ja also die haben jetzt irgendwie gerade 10 10 stück
bestellt und wäre halt gut wenn es dieses jahr noch klappt weil wegen prämie und so habe ich
gesagt ja ja das bin ich jetzt ja auch im august schon da lieferzeiten extrem lang sind aber meinte
also ja wir können mal gucken ob da einen von denen diese bestellt haben quasi meiner
wunsch konfiguration entspricht oder aber das auto hier wo ich jetzt wo ich muss ich gerade
drinne sitze das müssen sie auch bald quasi los werden weil vor für zeit irgendwie endet
und am ende war das halt zehntausend euro billiger als ein neuer der exakt so konfiguriert
wäre wie ich es hätte haben wollen dachte ich mir so ja komm er muss ja nicht mehr geld ausgeben
als notwendig jetzt gucken wir uns aber das wird fertig an wieviel kilometer ich weiß nicht genau
sieben ne moment ich kann es ihr sagen ich guck mal gerade aktuell rein aus dem bauchhaus würde
ich sagen 7000 aber da haben das letzte mal im stream die leute gesagt das kann nicht sein so
viel darf man vor für auto gar nicht haben ich weiß es gar nicht genau also ich habe gerade
3139 auf dem counter seit dem letzten reset also 3139 kilometer seit dem letzten reset vom
vom fahrt zähler so und insgesamt habe ich 10134 kilometer das kommt auch ungefähr hin mit 7000
kilometer oder ich weiß aber nicht ob ich den ich vielleicht mehrfach gesetzt gesettet habe es kann
auch sein dass ich die das schon mehrfach gesettet habe diesen fahrt counter wahrscheinlich keine aber
gehen wir mal von 7k aus zumindest war es halt eine ganze ecke billiger und deswegen habe ich
genommen ja die prämie war schon quasi mit mit einkalkuliert also ich habe nicht noch mal extra
prämie gekriegt aber da würde neu halt auch 35k kosten wenn sie prämie schon abzieht also ich
finde es ist preislich ganz ok gewesen für das was man kriegt und mir war es halt so nach dem
elektroauto ich muss sagen jetzt so nach ungefähr einem halben jahr ja wie gesagt ich habe es im
august im august habe ich den gekauft jetzt so nach einem halben jahr elektroauto muss ich sagen ich
finde es immer noch nice ich würde auch das auto wieder kaufen so ein paar sachen wäre natürlich
schon nice gewesen ja zum beispiel das mit der mit der mit der rückbank die man klappen kann und so
was und ein paar dinger sind auch nicht so toll gemacht ja zum beispiel dass die frontkamera
manchmal nicht will aus irgendwelchen gründen selbst wenn das wetter gut ist keine ahnung warum
das so ist dann geht dann beispielsweise die verkehrschilderkennung und sowas nicht richtig
das ist zwar selten aber manchmal ist es aus nicht erkennbaren grund wie viel fährst du im
jahr ich fahre mehr als sonst seitdem ich das neue auto habe ich bin mir aber gerade nicht sicher ich
kann dir das nächstes jahr im august sagen weil da gucke ich einfach in meinen home assistant und
stelle fest wie viele im jahr gefahren bin also jetzt bin ich seit august ungefähr wenn das stimmt
was in meinem home assistant steht bin ich seit august 3000 das ist ein bisschen wenig eigentlich
aber gehen wir mal von aus dass es stimmt dann bin ich 3139 kilometer gefahren seit august das
heißt in einem halben jahr also fahre ich irgendwie 6000 kilometer im jahr oder so und ich muss
übrigens auch demnächst zum händler stand drin muss wieder die firme update machen oder sowas
ne du dankeschön für den sub also ich sehe schon ich fahre nicht viel was ich das auto benutze
ja eigentlich nur zum ab und zu einkaufen zu irgendwo in die hier in die nähe irgendwo
hinfahren zu einem amt oder so oder halt mal ein bisschen hier neben ins ins gelände zum wandern
nicht viel also ich fahre damit weder regelmäßig auf die arbeit noch fahre ich da regelmäßig
irgendwie längere strecken oder sowas das heißt für mich ist das auch genau das richtige so ein
kleines elektroauto wenn ich jetzt regelmäßig irgendwie 300 plus kilometer fahren würde dann
würde ich mir natürlich kein elektroauto mindestens ein kleines elektroauto kauft und
weil man halt wirklich sagen muss das ist zwar ein kleines auto also hier immer noch von meiner
meiner kiste ja es ist zwar es ist zwar ein kleines auto aber innen drinnen also ich erzähle euch
jetzt nicht dass es groß ist oder so das ist das gegenteil von geräumig das auto es ist aber schon
ganz ok aber konfigurieren man das in gibt es einfach aber also wie gesagt das sieht auf dem
bild fast noch geräumiger aus als es ist also mit zwei leuten passt sie hier ohne ohne probleme
nebeneinander das ist nicht das ding das geht und hinten hinten passen theoretisch auch noch zwei
drauf wobei die größte bestückung die wir bisher gefahren sind waren drei leute im auto und das ist
jetzt schon gerade gerade hinten ist das dach auch ein bisschen niedrig also super bequem ist es nicht
wenn ich mir überlege dass leute wie mein opa und so mit dem alten 500er quasi schon also leute
so die generation von meinem von meinem opa irgendwie mit dem alten mini 500er irgendwie
nach italien gefahren sind in urlaub dann darf man sich in dem ja auf jeden fall nicht nicht
beschweren aber was ich was ich eigentlich was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ich meine das ist zwar
so ein kleines kleines furzauto aber die technik drinne finde ich wirklich sehr nice also das ding
hat hier eine lade lade station für ja wenn man das irgendwie groß machen könnte das hat das hat
eine lade station fürs handy so induktives laden da kannst du ein handy reinschmeißen
lädt das handy auf hier oben hast du auch noch einen usb anschluss für entweder laden oder
irgendwie connect zu karlplay karlplay kann das ding also karlplay und android auto kann das ding
wireless oder eben per usb hier unten hast noch zwei usb anschlüsse und du hast halt recht gutes
display finde ich praktischen praktischen das ist nicht ios das ist android da drauf das ist
irgendein android abkömmling der da drauf läuft sieht man auch an den icons und an dem menü und
alles aber du kannst dich kann sich per karlplay verbinden das navigationssystem beispielsweise
also das radio und das navigationssystem was jetzt hier gar nicht angezeigt wird normalerweise
müsste hier das navi dazwischen sein noch das ist gar nicht dabei also das hier ist karlplay ja
aber der rest ist android das benutze ich nicht ich benutze eigentlich nur über karlplay das
ganze hier da habe ich dann navigationszeug drauf und musikzeug ist dann auch da drüber aber finde
ich ganz gut gemacht und das hat theoretisch auch du kannst das ding auch bedienen per sprache habe
ich am anfang mal gemacht übrigens kennt ihr kennt ihr das schlüsselwort du musst sagen hey fiat allein
schon das finde ich so cringe dass ich nicht mache aber die sprachsteuerung ist nice to have ehrlich
gesagt ich verwende sie so gut wie gar nicht du kannst da zum beispiel sagen hey fiat mir ist kalt
und dann macht sie klimaanlage alles ist eigentlich schnick schnack benutze ich benutze ich so gut wie
gar nicht ich drücke eher die knöpfe hier das ist das ist eigentlich alles ganz gut gemacht also
die technik ist halt nice für so ein kleines kleines furzauto dementsprechend ist halt auch
teuer du kannst elektrische fenster auf und so gibt es jetzt ja schon lange hast du hier für
für fahrer beifahren kannst ein spiegel einstellen du kannst du hast so ein tempo halt assistent für
die autobahn du hast verkehrsschilderkennung du hast so ein warnsystem wenn ihr eine über
zebra streifen rennt dass es ist auch gut dass es knöpfe sind ja das war mir wichtig dass ich
knöpfe auf dem lenkrad habe und kein touch weil auf touch auf dem lenkrad habe ich wirklich
kein bock du kannst theoretisch auch hier das das hat zwei funktionen also kannst hier drüber
entweder gespräche führen mit deinem handy wenn das angeschlossen hast oder du kannst auch
siri benutzen wenn man siri sprachdings kann es kann es damit auch koppeln und weil ich ehrlich
gesagt glaube ich noch nie wirklich im auto beim fahren telefoniert hab damit also ich werde
manchmal angerufen aber ich gehe dann meistens nicht dran oder drück weg ja ich habe das mal
ausprobiert wie sieht es mit navi aus ja sieht man jetzt hier auf dem display nicht aber ist da
auch dazwischen das navigationssystem ist ganz ok verwende ich aber nicht weil ich immer k-play
navigation mache also ich verwende von diesem system kaum was also ich verwende wieder die
musik noch das navigationssystem ich mache das alles über k-play also ich benutze entweder
google google maps oder oder ways wobei was ein bisschen rum backt in letzter zeit und nicht
richtig startet man k-play neu verbinden muss und musik mache ich auch über über k-play also
insofern das einzige was ich von diesem steuerelement benutze ist die klimaanlage
und heizung dass man sieht wie die lüfter eingestellt sind die klimaanlage kann man
übrigens auch alles hier unten drüber steuern also kannst hier unten auch einstellen am besten ist
wenn man gar nicht weiß was man macht ist man drückt drückt auf auto weil dann ist aber ist
der lüfter vielleicht ein bisschen laut aber im großen und ganzen bleiben deine scheiben auch
frei und beschlagen nicht und das coole ist du kannst es auch preconditionen also du kannst
dann beispielsweise vom handy aus einschalten dass das auto sich aufwärmt wenn es zugefroren ist
das finde ich sehr nice also ich musste noch nicht einmal scheiben kratzen bei dem ding ich
gehe dann aufs handy macht bitte jetzt einmal heizen und dann heißt das und wenn ich ins auto
fünf minuten später einsteige ist die scheibe frei aber es vielleicht ein bisschen wischen oder
so aber dann ist weg ja und die technik an sich ist wirklich wirklich nice gemacht ja fiat ist
jetzt kein tesla was das angeht höhere sagen ich habe auch kein tesla ausprobiert weil für mich
e feststand so viel geld will ich fürs auto nicht ausgeben tesla bist ja was weiß ich 75k plus
nach dem motto so viel wollte ich dann für so für jemand der einfach nur immer um zwei ecken
fährt doch nicht ausgeben ja also von der technik von der techniker ist das jetzt sicherlich kein
tesla was da dann möglichkeit hast du hast kein steam ich kann kein steam drauf laufen lassen
tesla kannst ja mittlerweile steam drauf laufen lassen und die möglichkeit custom abfragen zu
machen und so ist auch hier nicht so gegeben wie beim tesla beim tesla kann sich alles mögliche
auslesen hier kannst du auch ein bisschen was auslesen wenn ihr was auslesen wollt gibt ein
projekt von mir auf github nennt sich fiat champ hat sogar 52 sterne mittlerweile da könnt ihr
ein paar sachen von eurem elektroauto auslesen ja zum beispiel könnt ihr auslesen wie die ladung
von der batterie ist der aktuelle kilometerzähler und solche geschichten batteriestand könnt ihr
heizung remote anmachen und solche geschichten habe ich extra programmiert als ich habe dieses
home assistant extra entwickelt im zuge dessen weil ich mir das auto gekauft habe und es keine
gescheite möglichkeit gab das in home assistant zu integrieren bisher deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
dann müssen wir das halt selbst machen es gibt das addon dafür ja aber die technik finde ich
wirklich cool also hat was sensoren wenn du zurück fährst sehr praktisch hier unten stellst du
übrigens das ist das ist übrigens die gang schaltung hier unten also gang schaltung ist
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben du hast im prinzip ja keine gänge du hast ja schon also
jetzt nicht 1er 2er 3er 4er 5er du hast parken wenn du auf parken drückst dann macht der
automatisch auch die handbremse an die handbremse ist hier das da in der mitte das die an der
einzige button mit einer led drinne dass du siehst ob die handbremse an ist oder nicht also was
parken du hast rückwärts du hast leerlauf und du hast fahren drive also im prinzip musst du
nichts anderes machen wenn du einsteigst wie schlüssel rein hier hinten man sieht es jetzt
nicht das hatte hinten so ein knopf drauf drücken du musstest du musstest muss das das pedal drücken
also muss die die bremse musst du drücken den einschaltknopf drücken und dann einfach nur
auf drive schalten und das war es und dann gas geben dann schaltet sich automatisch die handbremse
aus und das ding fährlos ja könnte man da eine app installieren die man selbst erstellt hat nein
es ist zwar ein android unten drunter aber das ist so ein abgeriegeltes android auto automotiv ich
habe schon gesehen dass manche leute das geknackt haben und es irgendwie geschafft haben da custom
zeug drauf zu kriegen habe ich letztens bei xtr oder so gesehen ich weiß nicht ob es so eine
gute idee ist also ich habe auch schon ein paar glitches gefunden in dem menü dass du android was
nicht offen ist ja das ist android automotiv oder wie das heißt das ist die geschichte die quasi
lizenziert wird an herstellern wo gar nicht wirklich erwähnt wird dass es android ist
ja dann hast du noch ein paar ganz andere coole sachen die für mich natürlich neu sind die es
in vielen autos schon lange gibt wie zum beispiel so in so einem tempo halte ding höhenverstell nicht
höhenverstellbare elektrische scheiben wie das scheibenheber so zum auf und zu machen
verkehrsschilderkennung also du hast hier oben so eine anzeige wie viel aktuell erlaubt ist wie
schnell du fahren darfst da kannst du dich aber nicht immer hundertprozentig drauf verlassen
das erkennt auch manchmal ziemlich ein mist also muss immer noch auf die schilder gucken also es
gibt zum beispiel eine stelle da gehe ich gerne hin wandern da muss man so ein bisschen den berg
hochfahren da steht ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob da am anfang doch ich glaube da steht am anfang
sogar ein schild dass man nur 30 fahren darf oder 20 oder sowas und mein auto ist immer dabei also
das ist wirklich so eine richtig kleine straße die in schlangenlinien so für fünf minuten den berg
hoch geht und der fiat ist der meinung darf man 100 fahren ich glaube wenn du da 100 fährst bist
in der ersten kurve im wald und da steht auch relativ sicher ein schild am anfang dass du nur
30 fahren darfst aber fiat ist der meinung nope interessiert mich nicht du darfst hier 100 mach
mal also das kann sie dich nicht so hundertprozentig drauf verlassen aber es ist es ist doch ganz cool
weil du immer mal wieder drauf gucken kannst du nach dem motto wie viel war jetzt noch mal 70 ok
ja also ich muss sagen
also jetzt am halben jahr elektroauto ich finde es nice aber ihr wisst ja was ich vorher als
auto hatte auch noch in grün ich hatte vorher so ein ding so das auch noch gebraucht ja also
ich hatte so ein teil also kannst du von ausgehen dass egal was du mir gegeben hättest ich alles
wahrscheinlich sich besser gefahren hätte als ein opel agila von 2001 kannst du eigentlich
von ausgehen warum ist jetzt eigentlich dieses bild hier markiert die ganze zeit browser was
ist los warum ist dieses bild markiert also weil ich es angeklickt habe ja so so ein teil so ein
teil hatte ich vorher also sprich das ist jetzt schon zum zeitpunkt als das ding auf den markt
gekommen ist war das kein auto was super modern war zur damaligen zeit und das ist jetzt quasi für
mich wie 100 jahre in der zukunft also ist ein komplett komplett anderes auto was also du kannst
maximal 150 fahren mit dem fiat ich habe es aber glaube ich noch nie gemacht das schnellste was
ich gefahren bin war mal test weil sie irgendwie so 145 oder was ich glaube dass du bei 150 schlicht
ergreifend einfach nicht nicht weiter gas geben kann der wird der geht da nicht aus oder so aber
du kannst wahrscheinlich einfach nicht weiter gas geben habe ich noch nicht habe ich noch nicht
ausprobiert hier neben hast du übrigens die anzeige wie viel wie heißt das überhaupt so
viel power du gerade ziehst also ich merke dass zum beispiel wenn ich den ja hat er hat er hat
so ein tempo halte ding hat er habe ich noch nicht ausprobieren ich fahre so gut wie nie auf der
autobahn woanders er lohnt sich dass ich hatte das kannst du hier neben drüber steuern hier guck da
sieht man es auch ein bisschen tempo hoch tempo runter und sowas da hat noch da noch mehr coole
features du kannst zum beispiel den spurwechsel antippen und dann musst du musst du selbst das
nicht ein und ausschalten dann dann dann blinkt das zweimal und du kannst drüber fahren und dann
geht es automatisch wieder aus so auch wenn du nur ganz kleines bisschen längst also er hat viele
coole features die ich beispielsweise auch gar nicht aus ausprobiert habe oder gar nicht benutze
du kannst zum beispiel hier unten auch den du kannst hier unten auch den den fahrmodus umschalten
das mit dem plinke hat so gut wie jedes auto also der agila hatte das nicht kann ich so viel kann
ich dir sagen das nicht du kannst hier unten den fahrmodus umschalten da kannst du umschalten
zwischen normal range und irgendwie irgendwie noch super super speziellen modus im super
speziellen modus schaltet er alles ab was strom braucht das ist wenn du wirklich die
maximale reichweite fahren willst der normale modus ist das wie man kennt gaspedal drücken
und bremse drücken für ja entweder gas geben oder bremsen es gibt aber so ein zwischen modus
dass du quasi gas geben muss mit dem gaspedal aber wenn du runter gehst vom gaspedal dann
bremst er ein bisschen und das abbremsen kannst du wiederum benutzen um dies um den akku um das
akku aufzuladen das ist jetzt nicht genau von one pedal driving genau sowas chillfreak ich
habe keine ahnung warum diese message geblockt wurde weil okay leute die message vom chillfreak
wird nicht angezeigt passt mal auf diese message hier wird nicht angezeigt weil weil es sex
sexuality gender oder sex related ist vielleicht weil pedal zu pedo so eine ähnlichkeit ist keine
ahnung wer weiß was twitch sich da gedacht hat ja gut jetzt habe ich lange nur über mein auto
geschwätzt insgesamt würde ich mir das teil wieder kaufen wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte
vielleicht mit ein paar anderen funktionen es gibt übrigens total viel zeug also das lohnt sich da
wirklich mal das handbuch sich durchzugucken du kannst ja auch hier diese sache umschalten also
du kannst hier für verschiedene verschiedene views was was du sehen willst hier drauf gibt
ja glaube ich acht verschiedene presets dafür hier kann es auch relativ viel einstellen und
die ganzen die ganzen buttons auch also da lohnt sich tatsächlich mal sich das handbuch zumindest
mal zu überschlagen weil hier oben noch zwei zwei buttons da kann man zum beispiel hilfe rufen wenn
man irgendwie einen unfall hat habe ich noch nie drauf gedrückt ja ansonsten bin ich ganz schick ich
würde ich würde es mir wieder kaufen ja und das fahren vielleicht noch eine eine letzte sache dazu
das fahren ist natürlich sind natürlich weltenunterschied laser warner oder besser
gesagt so so so ein erkennungs ding hat er auch als er würde er würde bremsen wenn er die oma
auf den usb man wie komme ich auf usb wenn er die oma auf dem zebra streifen flitzt mit ihrem
rollator dass das würde es mitkriegen habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gemerkt also der hat auch so
dinge wie wenn du über 60 fährst und zu nah an eine linie kommst wo du nicht rüber fahren darfst
dass der dann erst mal eine warnung hier dir anzeigt und ansonsten dann auch so kann man
übrigens ausschalten ansonsten so ein bisschen wackelt am lenkrad dass du weißt okay jetzt
fahren wir wieder rüber man kann das einstellen dass der auch ein bisschen gegen lenkt aber das
habe ich auf die niedrigste niedrigste stufe stufe gestellt ja aber so wie das befahren ist
ohne scheiß im vergleich zum agila sind da natürlich welten dazwischen ich hatte ja einen
agila von 2001 und dann auch schon nicht der mit dem besseren motor sondern mit dem kleinsten also
wenn du da selbst wenn du da einen tractor überholen wolltest mit dem agila da musst du
im endeffekt gefühlt erst mal eine halbe minute beschleunigen dass du überhaupt schnell genug
warst dass du an dem vorbeigekommen bist also konnte im prinzip auf straßen wo ab und zu mal
einer entgegenkommt prinzipiell vergessen mit magila leute zu überholen war war nicht war nicht
drinnen und das war koste koste komplett knicken ich weiß nicht wie viel wir können mal gucken wie
viele ps der agila ich weiß ich gar nicht opel agila 2001 ok
75 ps im moment gab sie nicht mit zwei varianten 75 und noch weniger
65 ok dann habe ich dann habe ich eher 65 ps gehabt mit magila also ich hatte so ziemlich
den schlechtesten motor im agila den es gab das ist übrigens kein opel agila kein alter
58 dann hatte ich ich glaube 58 ich glaube 58 ps hatte ich das war wirklich nix dolles
du hast wie gesagt du hast du hast gefühlt eine halbe minute beschleunigt dass man
traktor vorbei gekommen ist und das ist mit dem natürlich anders das ist das ist mit dem
natürlich anders also was was ich was ich mittlerweile sogar ganz gerne mache ist wenn
es irgendwelche leute an der ampel gibt mit ultra fetten autos und so die sich dann extra
an dir noch vorbeischieben auf die linke seite dass er dann denkt also ein kleines furzding das
hängen wir jetzt ab dann gebe ich auch ganz gerne mal gas bis dahin wo man fahren darf und die
meisten kommen da nicht hinterher wenn du bei dem gas gibst also wenn du das ding ist ziemlich
schnell auf 100 ich meine das kann es jetzt natürlich nicht kann es jetzt natürlich nicht
vergleichen mit so einem richtig super gut motorisiertem auto aber da ist glaube ich in
ich glaube in sieben sekunden von 0 auf 100 das ist jetzt kein irgendwie bmw porsche sonst was
mäßig aber das ist schon ganz ok und wenn du da gas gibst ist das also bis 70 bis 70 ist der ist er halt wirklich sehr zackig ja genau also bis
70 ist er wirklich sehr zackig da drückst du drauf und du merkst direkt also du sitzt und es macht
einfach nur das kann man kann man schwer beschreiben so so bei klassischen bin ich der große autofahrer
aber beim agila war das so wenn du angefahren bist hat es erst mal und dann hast du gemerkt
dass das ding ist erst mal ist erst mal angegangen hat krach gemacht dann ist es halt hast du halt
gemerkt gehts gehts vorwärts ja und bei dem drückst du auf das gaspedal drückst auf das gaspedal
und es macht quasi beim instant beim runterdrücken des gaspedals macht das voll vorneweg also du
hängst nahezu jeden an der ampel ab mit dem teil wenn du willst ja wenn du willst ist also wenn
es darauf anlegst hängst du eigentlich fast jeden jeden ab an der ampel ja und ist aber so bis 70
auch bis 100 dass das das meiste aber schneller fährst auf normalen strassen ähnlich danach klar
wenn da einer mit mit was ordentlich motorisiertem lebe da ist er auch vorbei also das schnellste was
ich bisher gefahren bin ist auf der ist auf der autobahn 145 147 oder so ich wollte es nicht auf
die 150 ankommen lassen und man muss sagen das fährt sich ganz fährt sich schon gut angenehm
bei über 140 wobei man sagen muss also du merkst schon anders das auto nicht unbedingt gedacht
ist 140 150 die ganze zeit zu fahren also das lenkrad ist viel zu viel zu leichtgängig finde
ich bei so hohen geschwindigkeiten da musst du wirklich genau aufpassen dass er aber nicht ein
bisschen zu viel dran rüttelt oder so das dürfte ruhig ein bisschen schwergängiger sein wenn
du irgendwie 140 fährst und du merkst auch dass das auch wie sagen so verbrauchstechnisch nicht
darauf ausgelegt ist dass du irgendwie permanent 140 150 fährst mit dem ding klar wenn du zum
autobahn fährst kannst du kannst du schon machen aber da verbraucht dann auch ganz ordentlich also
dass ich würde mich da nicht wohlfühlen irgendwie jetzt eins zwei stunden damit 150 rum zu rum zu
düsen was dir eh selten am stück machen kannst naja so viel zu meinem auto ich weiß gar nicht wie
man darauf gekommen sind dass wir irgendwie fast eine halbe stunde oder so über mein auto
geschwätzt haben aber so sieht es aus auto stellt wie viele kilometer fährst du ungefähr ja wir
können es anhand meiner meinem home assistant ausrechnen also ich habe wohl seit august ungefähr
3200 kilometer gefahren august das ist ungefähr ein halbes jahr her naja ende august habe ich den
gekauft nicht nicht wirklich aber neunter 10 11 12 ja doch doch doch kommt hin ja halbes jahr
halbes jahr habe ich ungefähr so 3200 kilometer gefahren es ist nicht viel andere fahre das
irgendwie den monat oder so oder noch mehr also können wir ausrechnen also ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob das stimmt also 533 kilometer ja das kann durchaus sein das kann durch ich glaube
das kommt ganz gut hin 533 kilometer im monat ja ja ich denke das könnte gut hinkommen wie gesagt
ich feier auch nicht große strecken also ich fahre mal hier zu einem abend oder irgendwie
in supermarkt oder irgendwo mal zum wandern hin aber weder jeden tag pendeln pendeln mit
dem auto noch irgendwie öfters mal längere strecken also sprich für mich ist das genau das
richtige auto in zwei tagen schläft er dann auch im auto oder nun gut ich gucke noch mal ganz kurz
im chat ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe ja das geht ziemlich zackig also das leute du musst das du musst das gaspedal auch gar nicht
groß durchdrücken also nicht groß groß reindrücken entlädt sich eigentlich die batterie stark wenn das
auto längere zeit steht nö nicht nicht nennenswert geht der hilferuf noch wenn der strom alle ist
wahrscheinlich wenn er ganz alle ist nicht aber das hat so eine gewisse reserve also wahrscheinlich
höchstwahrscheinlich geht das noch also ist meine nicht mein alter mein altes auto naja gut
gut jetzt gucken wir uns aber endlich mal das video an ich habe schon wieder alles vergessen
um was es hier ging irgendwie irgendwie sind wir von da jetzt auf mein auto gekommen keine ahnung
ich weiß auch nicht ich glaube doch ich glaube ich weiß es wieder es ging darum weil fiat die
auslieferung so verkackt ja da bin ich drauf gekommen weil fiat die auslieferung gerade so
verkackt dass hier irgendwie um geräte auslieferung auch ging jetzt jetzt weiß ich wieder ok alles klar
ok let's go was so was ok unternehmen nicht an diese mikroschricks haben konnten schätzungsweise
zwei bis vier millionen autos nicht gebaut werden viele leute vergeblich auf die ps5 gewartet
am ende vom video verlinke ich euch übrigens noch ein video dazu also nicht zu ps5 sondern
zum chip mangel generell aber schauen wir mal ja und das war die pice kosten jetzt 100 euro obwohl
sie 30 kostet daran dass die produktion von mikroschricks auf wenige regionen beschränkt
also vor allem ein land beziehungsweise eine firma hat fast schon ein globales monopol auf
die produktion das ist taiwan beziehungsweise die firma hier ist moment moment taiwan frag
mal china wie das land heißt die sehen das ganz anders das ist das ist insel china wenn
du die fragst taiwan gibt es nicht bei den diese firma allein produziert etwa 53 prozent der
halbleiter auf dem weltmarkt schaut man sich die neuesten und fortschrittlichsten generationen
an mikroschricks unter zehn nanometer an sind es sogar 92 prozent und damit ist sie neben samsung
auch einer der beiden einzigen unternehmen die diese produzieren könnten mikroschricks sind
ja wirklich hochkomplexe bauteile die aus integrierten schaltkreisen transistoren und dioden
bestehen die wiederum alle aus halbleitern hergestellt werden deswegen werden mikroschricks
und halbleiter auch oft so als synonym verwendet die mikroschricks die bilden später ein zentrales
element in der steuerung von den elektrogeräten der prozess zu so mikrochip der ist wahnsinnig
aufwendig technisch sehr sehr anspruchsvoll also ich breche mal ganz kurz auf so ein paar wenige
schritte herunter also basis von jedem schips ist ein sogenannter wafer die bestehen meistens
aus silizium welches eingeschmolzen wird und anschließend in so hochdünne schäden geschnitten
wird und das ist habe ich einen hier liegen also keinen ganzen wafer und auch keinen den man
irgendwie noch benutzen könnte sondern so einen aus wie es aus schuss aus schuss produkt die sind
wirklich mini mini dünn die sind wirklich extrem und das was ich habe ist schon ein bisschen
bisschen älter es hat keinen sinn warum ich das habe ich habe das mal weil es cool ausschaut ja
also nichts dass man damit damit machen kann und die sind wirklich richtig dünn und die sind auch
sehr sehr flach und glatt und alles kennt ihr diese kennt ihr diese spiele dies oftmals in so
ferien ferien veranstaltungsdinger und so gibt wo man diese so er hockey heißt das glaube ich
wo man so so nen so nen ja genau so ne scheibe so über so nen felt rüber schnickt mit mit so nem
wafer kannst du quasi er hockey spielen ohne ohne dass da luft von unten runtergeblasen werden muss
also die dinger sind so die sind so so flach und eben wenn du die wenn du die flach über auf
den tisch wirft dann kleiden die noch auf ihre eigenen luft schicht unten drunter eine weile
also das ist schon cool cooles ding dieser wafer unser wafer der wird im nächsten schritt poliert
und mit so einem licht empfindlichen fotolack beschichtet als nächstes wird der chip belichtet
und dieses belichtungsverfahren das heißt fotographie und darauf werde ich gleich nochmal
genauer eingehen denn das ist ziemlich entscheidend die struktur die auf diesen wafer dann übertragen
wird die bestimmt seine späteren eigenschaften durch eine maske mit diesen strukturen wird nun
das licht auf diesen wafer gestrahlt und verändert dann an den stellen die es trifft die chemie von
diesem fotolack und die prozesse die wiederholt man dann mehrmals bis so eine dreidimensionale
struktur ist der wafer der beinhaltet nun ganz viele identische schipps die nun einzeln
herausgeschnitten werden können der schritt bei dem die muster auf die schipps gedruckt
werden ist der entscheidende denn je mehr muster und somit transistoren auf eine platte
passen desto effizienter schneller und stromspannender wird auch dieser chip sein das ist gerade im
high tech bereich also bei high tech geräten oder auch sowas wie der robotik oder sowas super super
wichtig und dass das ganze funktioniert das hat tatsächlich mit der wellenlänge des lichts zu
tun licht lässt sich ja auch als welle darstellen und die wellenlänge die beschreibt jetzt den
abstand zwischen zwei wellenbergen rotes licht hat zum beispiel eine lange wellenlänge wie man hier
auf dem spektrum sehen auf der anderen seite ist das licht mit der sehr kurzen wellenlänge
das ist dann zum beispiel violettes oder ultraviolettes licht also uv licht die wellenlänge
die entscheidet jetzt also wie filigran die struktur auf den chips werden kann das ist
vergleichbar mit zum bleistift und wie dick die linien werden bisher kommt meistens eine
wellenlänge von so 193 nanometer zum einsatz das ist dann im ultraviolettenbereich also der
bereich den unser auge schon gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen kann ihr habt in den letzten monaten
schon einiges von unserem kooperationspartner ich finde es gut dass sie für den sellout wenigstens
komplett anders farbiges hemd anziehen dann weiß man wenigstens wo sellout anfängt und
sellout aufhört die was bitte schön die was bundesagentur für sprung innovation was
das habe ich auch richtig verstanden oder ihr habt in den letzten monaten schon einiges von unserem kooperationspartner sprint der bundesagentur für sprung innovation mit was ist sprung innovation
das ist bestimmt wieder übelst pepega übersetzt und die meinen damit was anderes
die disruptive technologie fördern soll alles klar alles wird disrupted sprung innovation die meinen das ist ok das ist quasi ein ein neuer ein sprung in der
entwicklung also jetzt nicht so nach dem motto es wird kontinuierlich in kleinen schritten weiterentwickelt
sondern so nach dem motto es ist so neu dass es ein großer sprung ist von jetzt zu dem was die
man das könnte man auch noch undeutlicher benennen oder bekommen und wir haben unter anderem zwei tolle live streams gemacht wir skippen das mal kurz pass mal auf
wir gucken einfach jetzt wo er wieder ein anderes hemd anhatten sobald er wieder ein anderes hemd anhatten wissen wir das sponsoring ist vorbei
jetzt hat er wieder ein anderes hemd an
man kann tatsächlich ziemlich vereinfacht sagen je kürzer die wellenlängen desto fortschrittlicher der chip und da kommt das unternehmen aus den niederlanden ins
spiel die forschen und arbeiten nämlich mit euv extrem kurzwelligen also extrem ultravioletten licht und was jetzt wirklich krass ist auch
ein globales monopol das hemd von ihm erinnert mich ein bisschen an meine fahrtfinder uniform von früher das hatte auch so ein ähnlich
farbe diese euv lithographie also die technik die chips bedruckt beziehungsweise belichtet und die
produktion erst überhaupt möglich macht asml ist ein unternehmen mit sitz in feltoben und wurde bereits 1984 gegründet
asml ist die einzige firma weltweit die diese maschinen herstellen kann und ohne die hätte keiner
der großen chip hersteller also ich war fahrtfinder samsung heute erfolg gehabt schauen wir uns mal an was diese
firma beziehungsweise die maschinen das macht man so bei den fahrtfindern zelte bauen zum beispiel lagerfeuer machen zelte bauen stockbrot machen
im wald rumrennen
so zeug eigentlich ziemlich unsinniges zeug aber für kinder ist es ganz nice also ich fand das super damals ich hatte aber ich hatte aber
kein bock mehr auf die fahrtfinder sobald ich sobald ich in die größeren also höheren da groups
kuppen gehen sollte wo das irgendwie ernster wurde da hatte ich kein bock mehr drauf ich bin da nur so
lange hin wie das einfach nur wir spielen mit gleich all drücken im wald war danach hat es mich nicht
mehr interessiert komischer kram da da muss man auch kam ich auch in als also richtig cringe teilweise gewesen so da
musste man so sachen schwören und so was bei den fahrtfindern ich weiß ich weiß nicht mehr fragt mich nicht
mehr was ich geschwört habe bei den fahrtfinder ich habe keine ahnung mehr vielleicht wenn ich wenn ich drüber nachdenke
gefällt es mir wahrscheinlich wieder ein ich glaube dass ich alten leuten helfe oder so und keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
weiß ich nicht mehr so besonders macht und was die auch anders machen also die base der chips ist auch hier
wieder dieser simple silizium wafer und auch die werden wieder beschichtet und anschließend belichtet aber
wir auch denken könnt erfolgt die belichtung mit eu v licht und das ist so weil es das licht zumindest
bei uns auf der erde nicht auf natürliche weise gibt also im weltall gibt es das licht hier bei uns
auf der erde ist das zum glück abgeschürt das ist auch gut so dass die meisten sachen die es da so an
kosmischer strahlung gibt bei uns in der atmosphäre oben erstmal stecken bleiben um eu v licht künstlich
zu erzeugen wird eine etwa buss große maschine verwendet der vorgang der startet mit einem der
stärksten laser systeme weltweit dieser laser wird eine energie von etwa 40 millionen laser pointer
ok wie viele laser pointer sind das jetzt in fußballfelder kann das mal jemand schnell
ausrechnen please dann verstehe ich das vielleicht auch aber es klingt auf jeden fall ziemlich stark
die frage ist sind das so die 0815 billig laser pointer dies bei uns gibt oder die illegalen laser
pointer von aliexpress die gibt es ja auch noch die aliexpress laser pointer die als die quasi
löcher in die wand brennen können aber als katzenspielzeug verkauft werden bei aliexpress
sozusagen kombiniert in einem und die energie des lasers muss nun in licht mit der richtigen
wellenlänge nämlich 13,5 nanometer umgewandelt werden und dazu kommt jetzt zinn ins spiel
beziehungsweise die verdampfung von zinnen winzige zintropfen die werden die werden mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 70 meter die sekunde aus dem generator durch so eine drüse geschossen
diese kleintropfen die werden anschließend zweimal von so einem laserimpuls getrocknet
zunächst einmal mit einer schwachen intensität um die tropfen dann wie so ein fandkuchen platz
zu drücken und der zweite laserimpuls der erfolgt mit extrem hoher intensität alle high IQs
verdampfen lässt und so ein plasma erzeugt und durch diese plasma erzeugung wird energie in
form von licht freigesetzt dieses licht ist das benötigte uv licht genügend uv licht
zu erzeugen muss der vorgang tatsächlich etwa 50.000 mal pro sekunde wiederholt werden
ok das heißt das richtige licht wurde jetzt schon mal erzeugt das muss nun zum bedrucken
der chips in diesen waferscanner geleitet werden zunächst wird das licht durch so ein
parabol spiegel oder auch sonnencollector genannt gebünde dann wird es über so spiegel
in die richtige position geleitet aber ist ganz wichtig diese spiegel reflektoren müssen
extrem glatt sein schon so eine unebenheit im nanometerbereich könnte das endergebnis
tatsächlich zerstören das zielen dieser lichtstrahlen auf diesem silizium wafer das
muss super super präzise sein und das ist tatsächlich vergleichbar mit einem laser
der vom mond auf eine münze auf der erde strahlt ok von da aus geht es dann weiter zum belichten
und für jeden wafer gibt es abhängig von seiner späteren funktion einen speziellen
bauplan und dieser wird auf eine art maske festgehalten durch die dann das uv licht
geleitet wird die maske die wird reticul genannt und diese wird nun auf den wafer projiziert
und das licht durch die freien einfach einen zins sniper gebaut so könnte man es auch
nennen ja in der maske dann weitergeleitet 360 noscope aus 10 super schnell hin und
her mal diesen gesamten wafer zu bedrucken oder auf einen wafer passen so bis zu 100
einzelne chips ja moment außer apple cpus die sind zu fett da passen bestimmt nicht
so viele drauf können dann in einer stunde mit dieser struktur versehen werden und damit
dann dieser mikrochip mit ihnen berechnung ausführen kann müssen weitere materialien
wie aluminium wolfram kupfer oder silizium verbindung aufgebracht werden und das jetzt
wirklich ziemlich verrückt wenig also bis so ein wafer fertig ist können bis zu drei
monate vergehen und die müssen drei monate keine fehler beim belichten machen das muss
da auch erst mal hinkriegen wenn in so super staubfreien räumen montiert die 10.000 sauberer
sind als die außenwürfe denn so ein einzelnes ist kein apple bashing das ist eine tatsache
die apple cpus sind mega dick nicht dick also nicht die dicke mega groß von der fläche
hier kann die ganze charge ruinieren ihr seht also das bedrucken der schipp rohlinge mithilfe
von diesen uv licht ist unglaublich komplex und deswegen wird die maschine auch als einer
der kompliziertesten geräte die jemals hergestellt wurde bezeichnet und nur etwa 140 dieser geräte
wurden in den letzten zehn jahren verkauft und eine maschine die kostet einfach mal 200
millionen dollar deswegen schnapper geht doch ganz ehrlich ist doch also ich mein klingt
jetzt krass für eine maschine aber irgendwie irgendwie auch im rahmen oder ich meine du
stellst damit mega high tech sachen her die sonst niemand auf der welt sonst herstellen
kann 200 millionen kannst du bestimmt auch für so einen fetten bagger ausgeben so ein
so ein ding wie sie im kohlebergwerk stehen haben
leisten konnten die größten drei tsmc samsung und intel machten 2021 fast 84 prozent des
geschäfts von asml aus insgesamt besteht eine maschine was intel ich habe es jetzt nicht
verstanden was samsung intel tsmc ja ja ok fast 84 prozent des geschäfts von asml überwundert
mich nicht eine maschine aus sieben modulen und bis zu 100.000 teilen asml hat sechs produktionstätten
auf der welt und wenn sie in andere länder verschüttet werden braucht es halt drei boling
747 40 frachtcontainer und zwar netzwaffel die erzählen viel was deutschland angeblich
jetzt großartig machen soll wir sollten ja auch bis 2018 glaube ich oder bis 2020 die
modernste IT verwaltung also die die die modernste IT behörden geschichten der welt haben ich
sehe sie bis jetzt nicht also da wird viel gesagt wenn der tag lang ist ich bezweifle
auch dass die leute die das sagen irgendwie was von der materie groß verstehen
das kostet eigentlich so eine maschine die die sp 32 chips macht das dürfte wahrscheinlich
auch so eine maschine sein weil die sp 32 wird glaube ich auch von tsmc werden auch von
tsmc gebaut oder das dürfte auch so was in der richtung sein da passen dann halt ein
bisschen mehr drauf die sp 32 chips sind ein bisschen kröber die sind nicht ganz so filigran
hier die sind ja auch steht doch stand doch irgendwie guck 40 nanometer sind die sp 32
chips also vielleicht ist das dann nicht diese generation sondern die letzte generation von
maschinen oder so die das macht aber wahrscheinlich werden die sp 32 auch mit so einer so oder
so ähnlichen maschine gebaut da reicht die billig question
lastwagen das heißt man kann wirklich sagen alle länder der welt sind von dieser niederländischen
technologie abhängig das wird auch erstmal so bleiben denn asml ist die einzige firma
die bereits in den 90er jahren auf die entwicklung von diesen eu v lithographien umgestiegen
ist was ihm jetzt halt den großen vorteil verschafft heute wird das unternehmen asml
auf 250 milliarden stonks was es wertvoller als innen macht und auch experten würde es
etwa ein jahr das war jetzt natürlich für es war jetzt hier natürlich nicht möglich
ein bisschen höher aufgelöst screenshot zu benutzen und auch experten würde es etwa
ein jahrzehnt brauchen für eine andere firma mit dieser technologie aufzuholen das liegt
jetzt nicht nur an der komplexität immer ganz davon abgesehen aufzuholen die entwickeln
es ja auch weiter und die haben übelst übelstes know-how du wirst wahrscheinlich auf der welt
gar nicht so viele leute finden die in der lage sind wenn du sagst hey ich will jetzt
auch so eine maschine bauen da brauchst du erst mal leute die ahnung haben von der technologie
dass du so was bauen kannst also die wird es jetzt auch nicht an jeder ecke geben fachkräftemangel
es gibt fünf experten auf der welt die wollen alle nicht zu mir für 30k im jahr fachkräftemangel
was soll das in der strategie die firma hat nämlich häufig exklusive deals mit den über
800 lieferanten die schon durchaus nötig sind und viele der zulieferer wurden auch
einfach mal direkt aufgekauft damit niemand dieses wissen abgreifen kann und damit kommen
wir direkt zum großen aber wenn man so möchte und auch zu einer ziemlich spannenden geschichte
drum herum also diese große monopolstellung von asml die wirkt natürlich auch ein ziemliches
konfliktpotenzial und vor allem zwischen den konkurenten usa und china rodelt ja momentan
eh schon so ein konflikt china chinesen in diesem bereich hochtechnologie branche da
geht es richtig zur sache die usa die haben sich im weg zur microchipindustrie gebahnt
indem sie den chip herstellern intel und tsmc ermöglicht haben dort mit viel von ziemlich
großen subventionen und ziemlichen steuererleichtung fabriken zu bauen und so auch auf dem amerikanischen
markt tätig zu werden und so wollen die usa in den globalen silizium handel einsteigen
und ihre abhängigkeit von asien beenden im august letzten jahres hat president biden
den so genannten chips act unterzeichnet ein 200 warum wir unterzeichnen die amis eigentlich
nur acts die haben 30 milliarden ja gut bei denen heißt das wahrscheinlich einfach so
aber immer wenn die irgendwas unterschreiben sind es irgendwelche acts das heißt wahrscheinlich
sowas wie verordnung dollarpaket als investition in die chipindustrie mit dem ziel chinas wachsende
dominanz zu durchbrechen zudem müssen die chip hersteller oder gesetz und subventionen profitieren
wollen einwilligen ihre chips in der neuesten verordnung nach china weiterzugeben doch auch
china wird weiter mächtig investieren das hat tatsächlich auch mit schijing pings made in china
2025 klaren zu tun china in mehreren bereichen unter an also eins muss man ja sagen wenn die
chinesen sagen 2025 dann meinen die auch meistens 2025 wenn wir sagen 2025 da kann es auch schon
mal 2060 werden gut ich meine die nehmen dann auch nicht so wirklich rücksicht wenn sie in china
der meinung sind wir brauchen an der stelle jetzt ein neues krankenhaus dann rücken dann hat auf
einmal 60 bagger an und ob da jetzt ein paar leute im fundament mit eingegossen werden ist
auch nicht weiter wild und dann geht es weiter aber die meinen das meistens auch wenn sie sagen
zu tun china in mehreren bereichen unter anderem der künstlichen degenz an die weltspitze bringen
soll doch sowohl die usa als auch china sind wie alle anderen halt von asml abhängig und da wird
es jetzt noch mal problematisch um einen vorteil vor china zu bekommen hat 2019 die trump regierung
die niederländische regierung erfolgreich dazu gebracht keine der neuesten uv maschinen nach china
zu exportieren bisher durften sie jedoch die maschinen älterer generationen die mit den
sogenannten duv lichtarbeiten noch exportieren und damit ging immer noch 16 prozent des umsatzes
von asml im jahr 2021 nach china es gibt jetzt auch da wieder eine forderung der beiden regierung die
auch noch ein strengeres exportverbot haben möchte es soll noch mal ausgeweitet werden und so dürfen
auch die älteren geräte nicht mehr verkauft werden asml wird von den usa gewarnt dass sie von bestimmten
moment tsmc kommt ja aus taiwan wo die chinesen der meinung sind das ist ja china also die
chinesische die chinesische taktik ist wahrscheinlich ganz einfach sie machen einfach taiwan wieder
offiziell zu china und dann easy gut ich meine an die niederlande können sie immer noch nichts
können sie immer noch nichts machen die wiederum in den usa hergestellt werden und wenn sie weiterhin
nach china exportieren können die usa dann auch wieder beschränken machen ihr seht also es ist
ziemlich am rodeln auf der welt und so eine firma asml die eigentlich mit ihrem monopol ziemlich
nice dasteht hat es dann doch eigentlich nicht so gut weil sie muss sich entscheiden welche partei
möchte ich gerade verärgern und auf welches geschäft will ich verzichten ja und an der stelle
muss ich eine sache euch sagen und zwar ja es wird eine woche pause geben bei was jetzt schon ich
bin im dschungel outfit ich werde mit dem lieben tomato licks eine dschungeltour machen davon
werde ich auch ganz viel auf ist das wegen sieht da aus wie bei den fahrtfinder jetzt ergibt das auch
sind kommt auf jeden fall rüber und hier geht es dann am dschungel outfit da lag ich doch gar nicht
so falsch mit fahrtfinder outfit oder
ok was haben wir was haben wir sonst noch
das ende von netflix und co der neue 6 moment warum hat krank einen teureren pc als ich na gut
weil es krank ist das auch vollkommen ok ist mich macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen sinn was noch
teureres zu kaufen wobei krank hat der krank könnte sich auch 10.000 euro pc kaufen man kann
es aber abziehen wahrscheinlich hat krank den pc noch nicht mal bezahlt ok was haben wir sonst
noch zu bieten was ist das raspberry pi 4 ram upgrade tutorial löte der extra ram so gut wie
kein land erkennt taiwan an doch wir erkennen doch taiwan an oder nicht erkennen wir nicht
taiwan an kennen sogar leute die waren in taiwan schon im urlaub machen wir nicht
warum machen wir das nicht weil wir machen das nicht weil wir uns das nicht mit den
chinesen verscherzen wollen oder warum erkennen wir taiwan nicht an aber ich halte es trotzdem
für fragwürdig dass wir das also machen wir das wirklich nicht ok
der vatikan erkennt taiwan an so interessant wusste ich nicht
so was treibt der typ hier raspberry pi 4 ram upgrade tutorial löte der löte
der einfach mehr ram dran just just do it
löte löte kolben raus und go let's let's go ist das text to speech ist das text to speech
ok der löte wirklich mehr ram auf den raspberry pi das ist interessant ja das ist text to
speech flux beste so fluss flussmittel heißt glaube ich auf deutsch das ist tatsächlich
für alles auch unabhängig von ram chips auflöten sehr praktisch wenn man ein bisschen flussmittel
hat da gibt es so stifte zum beispiel da kann man flussmittel auf die löschen dann dann
fließt das löschen einfach viel besser an die stellen wo es hin soll
ja löschen mit flussmittel drin ist auch nicht verkehrt aber trotzdem wenn du drumherum
noch ein wenn du die sachen noch ein bisschen mit flussmittel einstreichst klappt es noch
besser also ich habe mir auch mal so ein stift gekauft vor einer weile so ein stift mit flussmittel
drinne das ist praktisch vor allem dort wo die sachen relativ eng sind und du was ich
will zwischen mehreren pins zwischen zwischen zwei pins also du willst den löten aber nicht
beide pins überbrücken und dann ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch wenn du da vorher flussmittel
drumherum machst dann ist nämlich die gefahr dass du irgendwie an den anderen dran schmierst
viel geringer also ich finde das lohnt sich auf jeden fall uns kostet nicht viel und wenn
du so zeug machen willst wie man hier manchmal sieht auf auf youtube so nach dem motto einfach
mal ein bisschen löschen an 20 pins vorbeiziehen und alles ist alles ist schön schön verlötet
dann brauchst du flussmittel und zwar ordentlich musst du musst du das ordentlich einschmieren
vorher sonst klappt das nicht und schmierst du das sonst wohin
der
Es ist nicht wirklich egal, solange es eine gute Arbeit ist, aus dem heißen Luft zu isolieren.
Jetzt stecke ich es an meinem Board-Handler, damit das Board nicht bewegt, während ich es arbeite.
Glaub mir, das macht deine Leben so viel einfacher.
Nach dem Aufschütteln der Chip-Perimeter...
Jetzt ordentlich, gib ihm!
... um den Board ein bisschen zu wärmen.
Gefluchst.
... um die Temperatur zu 400°C um den Memory-Chip zu desoldern.
Be careful when desoldering the original chip, since they use unleaded solder that is harder to melt than regular or leaded solder.
And if the solder isn't completely molten when you pull on the chip, the chances of you...
Wisst ihr, was ich mir immer denke?
Diese Komponenten da drinnen, wenn die die löten mit so heiß, mit so heiß Luft...
Die Komponenten sind doch gar nicht ausgelegt für irgendwie 400°C.
Ah, 300 wahrscheinlich.
Da besteht doch immer eine gewisse Chance, dass sie kaputt gehen, oder?
Das denke ich mir jedes Mal, wenn ich so einen mit heiß Luft da sehe.
Ripping some of the pads off are very high.
So make sure the solder is molten before pulling on the chip.
A good way of telling if the chip is ready to come off is by nudging it ever so slightly.
And if it moves and then springs back to its position, it means that the solder is molten and you can safely pull on it.
Okay.
After removing the chip, we need to replace or at least dilute the unleaded solder.
Das kannst du aber auch nur machen, wenn du ein gescheites Vergrößerungs-Mikroskop hast, oder?
Weil sonst siehst du ja nix.
The way we do this is simple.
First, we apply a little more flux and use a soldering iron set to 360° to make it drag a solder...
Guck, das hier, das funktioniert ohne Flussmittel überhaupt gar nicht, was der jetzt macht.
Das hier, das kannst du ohne Flussmittel einfach mal komplett vergessen.
...making drag a solder blob above the pads on the board.
It is important to be gentle and to go slow to avoid ripping pads in the process.
Then we will use some solder wick to wipe the solder from the pads so they are nice and flat.
Please apply as little pressure as possible when cleaning the board with the solder wick to avoid damage to the pads.
Das ist quasi so ein bisschen Kupfer... Kupfer...
Wie nennt man das? Kupferdraht? Kupferwolle?
Keine Ahnung, wie sowas heißt.
Als Kupfer ist das.
Cleaning all of the solder from the pads is crucial to properly soldering the new chip in place.
Even one pad with enough solder left on it could lift the chip in a way that fails to make proper contact with other pads.
Das wäre mir persönlich viel zu filigran, das würde ich daheim gar nicht machen.
As you can see, the flux now looks a little burned already.
So what I like to do now is just wipe it off with 99% isopropyl alcohol so it is clean and ready for us to apply fresh flux and begin soldering the new memory chip.
Also when I cleaned the old flux I saw a few spots that needed to be cleaned a little more so I did that.
This upgrade may have been pointless in the past when the prices of Raspberry Pi models were normal, but nowadays this is the cheapest way to get your hands on the 8GB version.
Ja, das stimmt wohl. Das stimmt wohl.
Ja, wenn man die Skills hat und die Hardware daheim um das zu machen, klar, dann kann man sie noch upgraden.
It is next to impossible to find Raspberry Pis in stock at authorized resellers, so the only option you have is the heavily overpriced second hand market.
If you have the equipment and the experience, it can be a fun little DIY project.
If you can't or don't want to do it yourself, you can always pay a professional to do it for you and again, it may be the cheaper option.
Woher weiß der denn jetzt wo die Kontakte sind?
Woher weiß der, wie er den RAM-Chip drauflegen muss, dass die Kontakte übereinander sind?
Meinung zu den 24GB RAM-Sticks von Micron?
Keine Ahnung.
Warum nicht?
RAM-Sticks sind RAM-Sticks, oder?
Kommt halt drauf an, wie viele Zellen oder wie nennt man das, wie viele Blöcke da drauf sind mit wie viel Speicher.
Die haben ne Markierung, ok, ja aber wo? Ich seh da jetzt nix.
Hier sieht man vielleicht wo man oben und unten ist, aber ansonsten.
Achso meinst du das?
Achso, ja.
Warum gibt's die Raspberry Pi's nicht mehr zu kaufen?
Weil es ziemliche Chip-Knappheit gab und die Dinger, wenn du sie kaufen kannst, unverhältnismäßig teuer sind,
sodass du dir eigentlich auch schon was viel besseres an Hardware kaufen kannst.
Für den gleichen Preis. Also es lohnt sich aktuell überhaupt nicht.
Hä? Warum hat er denn jetzt das Klebeband nochmal neu abgemacht? Das hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Ah, achso, weil das hier dran kommt, hätte das nicht einfach abschneiden können?
Hä, hä, ja.
Ich erkenn da gar nix.
Ah, doch, doch, doch. Man hat's tatsächlich gerade gesehen.
Boah, Alter, aber ohne Mikroskop ist da nix.
Ja, man hat's gesehen, es zieht sich dann da fest, aber ohne Mikroskop ist da nix.
Wird dann die Verfügbarkeit jetzt wieder besser wahrscheinlich, ja?
Es wird besser, aber noch ist es teuer, ja.
Bootscheb.
Boogscheb.
Aha, okay, gut zu wissen, dass das geht, machen werde ich es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Es gibt viele Raspberry Pi Alternativen von der Hardware, aber es gibt keine Raspberry
Pi Alternative, was das Ökosystem angeht und die 30 Milliarden Tutorials und Header
und Custom Libraries und hast du nicht alles gesehen.
Das gesamte Ökosystem ist halt einfach das Beste beim Raspberry Pi, auch die offizielle
Plattform, also das Debian-Based System, das ist super supported über alle Systeme aktuell.
Also es gibt genug Hardware Alternativen zum Raspberry Pi, aber das Ökosystem ist halt
nirgendswurf auch anrufansatzweise vergleichbar, ja.
Es ist aktuell leider so.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ziel, Doktor werden, das Gehalt als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter an der Uni.
Ich würde mal darauf tippen, dass es nicht allzu viel ist.
Raspberry Pi Alternatives, wisst ihr was, das können wir tatsächlich mal gucken.
Ich habe lange kein Linus Tech Tips Video mehr geguckt, weil mich da vieles nicht so
richtig anspricht, aber, nicht mal richtig anspricht, aber das könnte man sich tatsächlich
mal angucken.
15 Minuten geht auch ganz gut, klar.
Guck mal hier, ich habe hier eine Erdbeere gekriegt.
Okay, ich wollte eigentlich jetzt gucken, dass da...
Okay, auf geht's.
Wisst ihr, wie kacke ich immer noch finde, jedes Mal, wenn ich hier dieses dumme Startmenü
verwenden muss zum rüberswitchen, es fuckt mich einfach so ab, Windows 11.
Okay, auf geht's.
Große Zacken sind schlecht.
Mein Ziel ist, Herr Doktor, ich erwarte dadurch finanzielle Vorteile.
Diese Zacke hier kann fast nur ein Messfehler sein, mein Ziel sind tatsächlich über 100.000
Euro Bruttojahresgehalt zu erhalten.
Es geht in der IT auch ohne Doktor.
Hi, mein Name ist Richard Schirme, ich bin Diplom-Ingenieur für Maschinenbau und ich
arbeite als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter an der TU Bergakademie Freiberg in Sachsen.
7 Uhr, auf geht's.
Also ich fange im Prinzip zu zeitig an, weil man hat mehr vom Tag, gerade auch vom Sonnenlicht
und das finde ich sehr schön.
Und das ist unser Labor.
Als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter beschäftigt man sich größtenteils damit, Dinge zu erforschen.
Man versucht halt etwas Neues zu entdecken.
Als allererstes müssen wir die ganzen Geräte starten.
Neues Entdecken auf Knopfdruck sozusagen.
Ich persönlich beschäftige mich mit Hochtemperaturmaterialien und untersuche, wie die sich halt unter
diesen Hochtemperaturbedingungen verhalten.
Privatpersonen kommen eigentlich tagtäglich damit tatsächlich in Kontakt, nämlich ihre
Heizung.
Das Hauptziel, warum wir überhaupt hier diesen ganzen Versuchstand haben, ist quasi die
Eigenschaften von Materialien zu bestimmen.
Allerdings neben der Probenverformung hat man gleichzeitig auch noch eine Verformung
des Versuchsstandes, was man ja eigentlich gar nicht will.
Das ist quasi das erste, was wir herausfinden müssen, wie groß ist die Verformung des Versuchsstandes
und damit können wir dann unsere Messdaten korrigieren und kommen dann auf bessere Ergebnisse.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt unseren Versuchsstand zusammenbauen.
Er hat das High-Performer-Mindset.
So, jetzt kommt unser Ofen drum herum.
Gerade durch meinen Opa, da hatte ich quasi schon in meiner Kindheit erste Berührungspunkte
mit solchen Themen und da kann das dann schon sein, dass das die technische Richtung quasi
schon von klein auf ein bisschen einprogrammiert wurde.
Der Ofen soll jetzt 800 Grad erreichen.
Das heißt, man sieht dann hier ein kleines Leuchten durch.
Naja, 800 Grad, so krass sind die jetzt auch nicht.
Und dann geht es jetzt los.
Das kann jetzt so eine dreiviertel Stunde ungefähr dauern, bis wir unsere Temperatur
haben.
In der Zwischenzeit.
Essen.
Leider nicht so viel, weil wir von hier keinen Zugriff auf das Institutsrechenzentrum haben.
Den TU Freiberg wurde vor zwei Wochen cybertechnisch angegriffen.
Muss der da wirklich dann jetzt 45 Minuten davor sitzen oder kann man da am wenigsten
ein bisschen rumlaufen?
Wahrscheinlich haben die eine Regel, dass immer einer im Raum sein muss, wenn die Geräte
laufen und sowas.
Es hat an der Uni kein Internet, deswegen konnte ich halt diesen Versuchsstand heute
nicht alleine lassen, weil ich mir am Institut nicht anschauen konnte, wie sich die Werte
verhalten.
Ich möchte an der Uni bleiben, weil ich derzeit promoviere.
Also mein Ziel ist quasi noch ein höherer akademischer Grad und das ist der Doktor.
Ich erwarte dadurch finanzielle Vorteile zu erhalten.
Ja, gibt's wahrscheinlich auch.
Aber ich denke neben dem Geld ist das wahrscheinlich auch was, das einem die Arbeit letztendlich
irgendwie zusagen muss.
Was bringt es dir, wenn du einen Doktor hast und den ganzen Tag das machen musst, wo du
vielleicht gar nicht so hundertprozentig Bock drauf hast, nur dass du dann viel Geld
verdienst.
Also, naja, kann ja jeder machen, wie er will.
Aber es funktioniert, 799,8 Grad, genau das wollen wir.
So, also wir sehen jetzt hier am Positionssignal, dass die Maschine verfährt und gleich wird
dann die Kraft auch ansteigen und dann werden wir dann hier auch in den Kurven sehen, wie
sie dann halt ansteigt.
Und was wir im Prinzip wissen wollen, ist diese Steige.
Ja, Cringe, Leute, falsch in der sechsten Nachkommastelle.
Das geht ja gar nicht an der Stelle, ne?
Wie steil ist diese Kurve?
Ich erwarte, dass es ein gleichmäßiger Verlauf ist.
Wenn wir da jetzt so große Zacken drin haben, dann ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen.
Man hofft natürlich, dass nichts kaputt geht, weil dann muss man nämlich den Versuchstand
nochmal auseinandernehmen und halt die kaputten Teile ersetzen.
Weil man hätte halt dann die Zeit quasi umsonst da gesessen.
Und jetzt?
Und was sehen wir da?
Bis jetzt sieht es gut aus.
So, das war's fürs Erste.
Also was bin ich sehend?
Janen Graf mit Verlauf, okay und was sagt mir das jetzt so genau?
Alles ist geklappt, wir haben jetzt dreimal unsere Versuchstandssteifigkeit aufgezeichnet
und jetzt können wir den Ofen...
Versuchstandssteifigkeit.
Ich hab gerade noch die Daten auf den USB-Pack gezogen, die werden dann ausgewertet und da
kriegen wir dann idealerweise unsere Versuchstandssteifigkeit aus.
Und jetzt können wir den Ofen...
Versuchstandssteifigkeit.
Ich hab gerade noch die Daten auf den USB-Pack gezogen, die werden dann ausgewertet und
da kriegen wir dann idealerweise unsere Versuchstandssteifigkeit aus, die idealerweise dreimal dasselbe anzeigt.
Die Herausforderungen an meinem Job sind definitiv, dass man sich mit Themen beschäftigt, die
man nicht einfach mal schnell nachgurgeln kann.
Also das funktioniert nicht, weil es allzu diesem Thema entweder noch gar keine Forschung
oder nirgends reichende Forschung gibt und dementsprechend muss man sich halt sehr sehr
viel selbst helfen.
Und dann muss ich den natürlich noch anpassen, weil das Programm so wie es jetzt steht ist
für Raumtemperatur und wir haben jetzt gerade bei 800 Grad getestet und dann muss ich noch
ein bisschen was ändern.
Was haben wir hier?
Aha!
Wieder so langsame, langsame Dinger, die hier verwendet werden.
Gib nur eins Leute, die coolen Leute würden das in Rust machen, weil Placingly Fast und
so.
Low-Performer-Sprachen hier wieder.
Siegmar Chat.
Wir hatten einen Kurs in der Universität, wo uns Programmieren beigebracht wurde, aber
nur in den groben Zügen, also so wie ich jetzt Programmieren kann, habe ich mir größtenteils
selber beigebracht.
Ist auch immer so und wird es wahrscheinlich auch so bleiben.
Also man braucht generell, wenn man sowas lernen will oder in vielen IT-Themen braucht
man da persönliches Interesse dran.
Diese Zacke hier kann fast nur ein Messfehler sein, möglicherweise ist im Versuchstand auch
was verrutscht.
Auf alle Fälle ist es nicht so, wie wir es haben wollen.
Genau deshalb macht man dreimal so eine Messung, damit man sich halt sicher ist, wie die Daten
aussehen.
Also ich muss jetzt die zweite Messung quasi als fehlerbehaftet erklären und dementsprechend
rausnehmen.
Rausgefunden, in dem Sinne arbeite ich, dass der Versuchstand tatsächlich eine Steifigkeit
aufweist, also dass es sich bei hohen Temperaturen verformt.
Und das erste was wir jetzt machen ist, wir bauen mal unser Hartmetallplättchen wieder
aus.
Ich tausche das jetzt gegen die erste Probe aus, die wir von einem neuen Material testen
wollen.
Alter, das macht gerade schon krach.
Der Versuch ist jetzt der erste in einer Reihe von Versuchen für exakt dieses Material.
Oh nein, Tossmusik!
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss!
Können Ihr mal die Musik bitte wegmachen?
Nein, die wollen die Musik nicht wegmachen.
Ok jetzt.
Jetzt gab es das erste Mal Kontakt zwischen der oberen Einrichtung und der Probe.
Und jetzt wird die Probe belastet.
Ich schätze mal wir werden irgendwas um die 600, vielleicht bis 1000 Newton sehen, vielleicht
auch weniger.
Wir haben das Maximum erreicht, das heißt, die Probe ist gerade dabei, zu versagen, einzureißen.
Probe versagt.
Quasi kaputtzugehen.
So, das war's.
Der Ofen hat das automatisch abgeschalten und jetzt kann es in aller Ruhe der Nacht über
abkühlen und morgen schaue ich mir dann die Probe an, wie sie aussieht.
Und da sieht man im Prinzip, dass die Kappe, also quasi der mittlere Teil der Probe, durchgedrückt
wurde und das ist halt das typische Probenversagen.
Brutto verdiene ich pro Monat 4.500 Euro, zusätzlich dazu kommt einmal im Jahr eine
Jahresonderzahlung.
Geht doch eigentlich.
2.000 Euro dazu und nach steuerlichen Abgaben bleiben mir dann circa 3.000 Euro im Monat
übrig.
Das ist doch vollkommen okay.
Gut.
Jetzt gehe ich im Prinzip nach Hause und jetzt kann ich am westlichen Tag noch ein bisschen
Zeit im Keller verbringen, was bauen.
Da ist die Werkstatt.
Ich baue auch selbst, also die Absauganlage ist selbst gebaut aus einem alten Laubsauger.
Bisschen mehr Beleuchtung wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Das ist quasi die Turbine nur noch.
Mein aktuelles Projekt ist dieses Stückchen Bohle da hinten.
Das ist ein Überbleibsel von meinem Tischprojekt und daraus soll ein Schneidbrett für die
Küche werden.
So, dann wird's jetzt gleich los.
Chat, ich würde das nicht überbewerten, was man da jetzt gesehen hat.
Da gehören sicherlich noch komplexere Sachen zu, was er macht.
Das liegt bestimmt auch mit daran, dass er dem Fernsehteam was zeigen musste und sowas.
Also er wird nicht den ganzen Tag rum sitzen und zwei Sachen erhitzen und dann heimgehen.
Nicht mal Plaus Bosch Cringe.
Okay, der Chat hat's wieder analysiert.
Der hat ein Armani-T-Shirt an und eine Ralf-Jagd.
Moment, ist das mit dem Reiter?
Sind die das mit dem Reiter, was auch die ganzen tollen Business-Coaches anhaben?
Reiter.
Reiter muss sein.
Jetzt drücke ich hier an zwei Seiten und es wackelt.
Sollte jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt umdrehe, nicht passieren, kann ich jetzt hier drücken,
wie ich will.
Da kippelt nichts mehr.
Für mich ist es ein gutes Hobby, wenn mein Hirn was zu tun hat, ich mich nicht langweise.
Ambitioniertes Ziel Tischbau zum Beispiel und da ist dann auch der besagte Couch-Tisch.
Der Tisch ist tatsächlich komplett selbst gebaut.
Ich bin definitiv stolz auf das Ding, es hat auch knapp ein Jahr gedauert.
Letztes Jahr im März habe ich das Holz gekauft und im Dezember habe ich es tatsächlich...
Von der Breite her würde ich sagen, da könnte man ein gutes Rack draus bauen.
Würde man aber ein bisschen anders machen.
Dezember habe ich es tatsächlich dann abgeschlossen.
Zwei Brötchen.
Ja eben.
Miete.
Alter, okay, das ist ja das, okay, das ist mitten in Dresden, kein Wunder, das ist ja
nix.
Zeig die Miete mal irgendjemand aus, was weiß ich, München oder so oder aus irgendeiner,
oder Frankfurt reicht ja schon.
Das ist...
Okay, die teilen sich das wahrscheinlich auch, aber selbst dann ist es wahrscheinlich
noch billig.
Unser Abendritual ist tatsächlich Brötchen schmieren und dann gucken wir eine Folge von
einer Serie, die wir uns immer aussuchen und essen unser Abendbrot.
Da geht was, damit kann er was anfangen, dann kann er danach sein eigenes Startup kunden,
was er gespart hat und dann täglich zwei Sachen erhitzen.
Jawoll, das ist BÄM, hau rein.
Das war's von mir und der Theo Freiberg.
Zu wirklich jetzt erfahren, was er da so geiles macht, hat man nicht wirklich, er hat zwei
Sachen am Tag erhitzt, das wird's aber nicht alles sein.
Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr euch genauso wie ich einfach bewerben und euren Job vorstellen.
Und hier könnt ihr...
GG Eats.
Der Begriff...
Okay.
Making of Linux.
11 Minuten, können wir uns tatsächlich angucken?
Macht das mal auf.
Wir haben viel zu viel Zeug offen, Moment, Moment, falsch, falsche Browser, hier müssen
wir hin.
So, excellent.
Alles klar.
Zu wenig YouTube offen, ja eindeutig, ich brauch noch mehr Tabs.
Das glaube ich, ups, äh, das, Alter, ich will diesen Chat messen, das glaube ich nicht.
Da gabs wahrscheinlich einfach nicht so viel zu zeigen.
Was ist so dein Fazit, Winner aus 11 nach ein paar Wochen, das fuckt mich immer noch
mega ab.
Wie viel RAM verbraucht dein Chrome gerade?
Moment, wo sieht man das, hier, ne, Processors, Memory, ja, also, sagen wir mal 4G, ungefähr
beides zusammen.
Oh, 4G, so ungefähr beides zusammen, geht auch.
Ist doch alles noch im Rahmen, wie viel RAM ich drinne hab, 64, ja, geht doch man, 4G,
RAM ist doch jetzt nicht so wild, also Chrome und Chromium zusammen.
Am besten ist hier immer noch Web Application 11, die verbraucht 470 MB, warum?
Warum verbraucht die 470 MB?
Guck mal, Leute, und wenn ich ein GIF abspiele, braucht die einen Gigabyte, Highly Optimized
Zeug, was ich da gebaut hab.
Wie viel braucht der, Highres, Pepe, Moment.
8 Gigabyte, wie viel verbraucht das, 700 MB, ok, das ist nicht sonderlich optimiert
alles, würde ich mal sagen, was ich da am Start habe, das liegt aber an der Bildgröße
wahrscheinlich, naja, es ist nicht Written in Rust, Placingly Fast, super Optimized.
Boah, Leute, ich bin irgendwie immer noch müde, das kann auch gar nicht sein, was ist
da los?
Wir sind jetzt schon über 2 Stunden am Aufwachen, Leute, bald gibt es Essen, ich hab Hunger,
aber noch nicht ganz, noch nicht ganz, ok, was wollen wir uns jetzt, gucken wir uns jetzt
als nächstes an, Making of Linux, oh, please allow me to interject for a moment, es ist
GNU plus Linux, ach, das hatten wir hier schon mal auf.
Ok, Making of Linux, auf geht's, ja, man hat ja, man hat ja den Linux Kernel nur übergangsweise
genommen, bis GNU, GNU HURT irgendwann mal am Start ist, wird das überhaupt noch entwickelt?
Tatsächlich, am 18.
Januar, HURT, was auch immer.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Codefolding in manchen IDE's, es ist sinnvoll, dass man Sachen
einfach ausblenden kann, ist schon sehr, sehr sinnig, ja, und irgendwie hab ich den Chat
zugemacht auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, das war nicht meine Absicht, den Chat zu schließen,
lass mal wieder aufmachen, aber ich hab ja immer noch hier den Chat, Chat-Folding, ja,
ja, dass war damals mega, mega Hardware, C, ach, ne, war nämlich C, aber C ist da auch
irgendwo in dieser in diesen Zeiten dann entstanden in 1969 after AT&T had dropped out of the Multics
project the first version was released in 1970 two years later rewriting Unix in a new programming
language C to make it portable then in 1983 Richard Stallman started the GNU allow me to
interject for a moment free Unix like operating system and as a part of his work wrote the GNU
GPL both very important pieces for the future of Linux and in 1987 Minix was developed by
Andrew S. Tannenbaum as a teaching tool for computer science students the operating system
intended for academic use was small and simple but restricted modification and redistribution
and wasn't powerful enough to serve as a full-fledged operating system for desktop computers
because it had a 16-bit architecture that wasn't well adapted to Intel's increasingly popular 386
design for PCs the microprocessor Linus was using at the time Minix couldn't accomplish what Linus
wanted it to have. Hat irgendjemand von euch mal als wo ich hier gerade diesen 386er sehe
hat irgendjemand von euch ich werde es nicht im stream anmachen weil das wirklich dice of cringe
ist hat irgendjemand von euch mal diese windows eins war es glaube ich sogar werbespot gesehen
wo dann die leute anfangen zu dansen und so das ist so ultra cringe wo sie dann singen das
ist window 386 das ist so schlimm ich kann das nicht zeigen dass es wirklich dice of cringe das
geht nicht das kann ich euch nicht zeigen. Windows 386 song genau das gucken wir uns nicht an das ist
wirklich der härteste cringe ever der möglich ist aber das kann ich nicht angucken das ist zu
schlimm nein nein das müsst ihr euch selbst angucken das müsst ihr euch selbst angucken das ist zu
cringy der window 386 song mehr cringe als die balmer developers ja auf jeden fall mehr cringe do so
und ich kann mich sogar noch dran erinnern ich habe mir auch mal was darüber gelesen die
story warum es linux heißt ist nicht weil er das selbst linux genannt hätte sondern weil
ich glaube ich vermute mal das kommt jetzt noch wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe
irgendein admin mochte den ursprünglichen namen nicht unter was er das hochgeladen hat und hat
es dann in linux umbenannt wo wir gerade geguckt haben wie es darum steht
torvolz startet mit einem task switcher und intel 8386 assembly language und einen terminal
driver dann als torvolz in seinem buch just for fun geschrieben hat, welches ich in der
beschreibung verlinkt habe, schreibt er endlich einen operativen system-kernel, den linux-kernel,
erst auf 17 september 1991 gemacht, wo torvolz die 10.239 lagen der sorgschritte für
den operativen system auf der internet und erinnerte andere developper zu beteiligen
dem projekte über zeit die linux-kommunikation wuchs und tausende von developpern aus der
welt beteiligte code bug fixes und neue featuren zu dem projekte diese approach zu development
open source development ist einer der wichtigen faktoren das beteiligt den Erfolg von linux
und an diesem point in dem video bin ich sicher eine handvoll von Leuten die unten kommentieren
es ist nicht linux linux wir haben jetzt schon oft genug in interjected for a moment ja wir
wissen dass es ein knol mehr nuanced than that linux-kernel ist linux aber was die meisten
Leute heute als linux nennen, ist genu mit linux-added oder genu linux genu hat eine
unglaublich wichtige Rolle in der Entwicklung von linux als wir es wissen, z.B. in den Noten
für linux 0.01, torvolz listet die genu software die linux runnen muss.
Schließlich gibt es ein knol von sich selbst.
Um ein funktionierendes System zu bekommen, braucht man eine schale, ein kompiler, ein
bibliothek etc.
Diese sind separatte teile und können unter ein strukturer oder noch leiserer Copyright werden.
Die meisten Tools, die linux benutzt, sind genu Software und sind unter den genu copy left.
Diese Tools sind nicht in der Distribution.
Was wurde eigentlich vor git benutzt?
Ja so komisches Zeug wie SVN oder CVS oder wie hieß dieses Ding noch mal was linux vor
git verwendet hat?
Irgend so was proprietäres Dings Zeug keine Ahnung.
Mercurial gab es dann noch, bazaar gab es teilweise noch, ähm genau, ähm aber wie
hieß das?
Ne ne ne linux hatte der Grund warum er überhaupt git entwickelt hat, war ja irgendein Streit
oder irgendein Problem mit dem Versionsverwaltungssystem was linux benutzt hat davor, das hat ihn
erst dazu inspiriert, git überhaupt zu entwickeln.
Das ist irgendwas total unbekanntes, ok wir fragen mal, bitkeeper, ja, bitkeeper, genau.
Wird nicht mehr developed, ja, daraufhin hat er, hat er git entwickelt.
Jetzt выполnet man trotzdem, doch ist esามeraremos Instagram und Twitter.
Es hat sichlk骑 Diet, auf gleiche Art und Weise ein genuanter Archiv.
Die Bezeichnung Linux ist anfangs nur für den Linux-König verwendet, was die meisten von uns kennen als GNU-Linux heute
eigentlich eine Kombination von GNU und Linux verwendet und wäre mehr oder weniger genannt als GNU-Linux
was die Kreativität von GNU-Linux vorstellt
Richard Stallman hat anfangs die Kombination Linux genannt, L-I-G-N-U-X
als er den EMAX-19.31-Editor im Mai 1996 veröffentlicht hat
Ich denke, GNU-Linux hat einen etwas schöner Ramp zu ihm
Die Geschichte hinter dem Namen Linux selbst ist eigentlich eine interessante
Es ist natürlich von dem Namen seiner Kreativität, Linus Torvalds und Unix verwendet
Aber vorher wollte Linus ihn Freaks nennen
Freaks? Stimmt! Genau, und das wurde dann irgendwie umbenannt von irgendeinem Admin, weil er den Namen nicht gut fand
Und dann hat Torvalds den Namen Linux verwendet, ohne Torvalds zu konsultieren, weil er nicht glaubt, dass Freaks ein guter Name ist
Ich bin enttäuscht, mit ihm zu reden
Nachher hat Torvalds den Namen Linux verwendet
Oh, und der Penguin-Maskott, den wir alle kennen und lieben
Sein Name ist Tux
Tux, der Kreativität von Linux
E-e-ein Penguin, das weiß ich, das weiß ich nicht
Moment, es ist ein Pinguin als Maskottchen, weil er gebissen wurde in einem Zoo von einem Pinguin, aha
Das ist ja nix, das ist ja nix, Chrome hat mittlerweile wieviel, 20 Millionen Zeilen oder so
Warte mal
Chat-GPT fragen
35 Millionen sind wir mittlerweile
Und das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her, glaube ich
Also man muss jetzt ohne Scheiß, Leute, es ist davon auszugehen, dass die Chrome-Codebase länger ist als Windows
Also der Browser-Source-Code ist umfangreicher als der Windows-Source-Code
Heute ist natürlich auch unter Linux deutlich mehr
Chubantu
Natürlich, by the way, was sonst, ne, also
Es ist, es ist auch nicht Knu, Linux, es ist ja eigentlich Arch-Linux
Und es ist teuer mit Lizenz
Was war jetzt da vor?
Was kam denn jetzt da eigentlich? Am Anfang war Red Hat, was kommt als nächstes?
Ah ne, die springen wild hin und her
Slackware, Slackware gab es auch noch relativ früh
Ich bevorzuge ja Debian zu sagen
Chubantu
Ja gut, CentOS ist ja dead
By the way
Der hat immer noch erzählt, was dieser Strich ist
Warum ist CentOS dead? Weil das umgestellt wurde auf irgend so ein komisches
Also mit CentOS 8 ist es kein Red Hat-Klon mehr, sondern irgendwie so ein komisches Rolling-Release oder was
Ich hab's gar nicht mehr genau im Hinterkopf
Zumindest ist dieses, wir machen einen Red Hat ohne Red Hat-Logos, ist jetzt nicht mehr
Ja, richtig
Arch ist das einzig wahre
By the way
Das Internet läuft auf Linux
Ok, das heißt ungefähr Linux mit allem was es so gibt dabei und Treibern und Geschiss ist ungefähr 30 Millionen, ungefähr so viel wie Chrome
Ich würde darauf tippen, dass allerdings Chrome noch mehr hat
Ja, was sonst, was sonst, sollen die in Web-Server mit IES laufen lassen oder wie?
Ja, wisst ihr was mich bei SpaceX irritiert? Angeblich sind ihre komischen Touchscreen-Panels, die sie haben mit Elektron erstellt
Also wir fliegen mittlerweile jetzt nicht im übertragenen Sinne, sondern wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes fliegen wir mit Javascript ins Weltall
Ach Daco, ich hab's übrigens auch probiert, dein Code ist abgelaufen oder nicht mal möglich leider
Da kann man nichts machen
Weil das hätte sich damals auch nicht träumen lassen
Aber muss man echt sagen, ich mein ernsthaft, du brauchst ein dickes, du brauchst echt ein dickes Fell wenn du Open Source Software entwickelst
Und dass er da schon so lange macht und quasi das größte Vorzeige Open Source Projekt, oder? Also da musst du dir viel Shit anhören
Er flamet auch mal ganz gerne, aber ich kann es irgendwo schon nachvollziehen, er übertreibt es auch teilweise richtig krass ja
Aber seit ein paar Jahren hat er ja gesagt, er hat sich ein bisschen zurückgezogen und ist jetzt reformt und flamet jetzt nicht mehr so viel rum
Das stimmt auch, er flamet nicht mal ganz so viel, nicht mal ganz so krass rum wie vorher, aber so ein bisschen ausrasten tut er immer noch ab und zu ganz gerne
Alles klar
Man hätte ja durchaus sagen und ein bisschen, also man hätte viel viel mehr erzählen erwähnen können, aber noch ganz gut der Überblick
Du tü tü tü tü tü tü tü
Machst du anders Fיח確ere? Nö
Bestimmt nicht
Ja wir haben auch Zen 2S bei uns auf der Arbeit
Ja, wir haben auch sento erst bei uns auf der arbeit
Deswegen sage ich ja das ist doof dass es das so in der art und weise nicht mehr gibt es gibt jetzt all mal linux und rocky linux
Und hast du nicht gesehen noch alles mögliche da haben die leute aber noch nicht so viel erfahrung mit und weiß halt auch nicht ob das
In fünf jahren zum beispiel noch da ist weil ganz im ernst wenn du im business enterprise umfeld bist du willst halt kein betriebssystem
Haben was abhängig ist von zwei entwicklern
Die dann vielleicht kein bock mehr drauf haben deswegen was sento ist ganz gut es war eine günstige alternative zu vollständig im rettet
Gut man könnte auch oracle oracle enterprise linux einsetzen oder oracle unbreakable linux heißt ja eigentlich wenn man genau ist
oracle bescheiden wie immer
Oracle unbreakable linux heißt das ja rey dankeschön für den sub
Ja dort wo ich arbeite zum größten teil wird das auch so laufen dort wo ich jetzt hingehe
Die haben also wie ich das verstanden habe haben wohl zum größten teil rettet lizenzen für ihre server also die geben richtig geld aus
Ne ne ne das hat mit stabilität gar nicht so sehr viel zu tun da gehts da gehts um mehr da gibt es geht um andere faktoren da gehts erst mal
Darum dass eine große business geschichte dahinter steckt dass man support kaufen kann wenn man das will
Dass man garantierte support laufzeiten hat und exzellent support wenn man das braucht
Also auch garantierte garantierte updates und alles mögliche und der hauptpunkt dürfte eigentlich sein
Dass du spezielle software hast die zertifiziert ist nur für zum beispiel rettet oder ubuntu und solche geschichten
Und die kannst du zwar ohne probleme woanders drauf betreiben
Aber du kannst es auch ohne probleme betreiben
Aber dann hast du wiederum probleme wenn es nicht richtig funktioniert dass dann der hersteller sagt ja dann installierst du erst mal auf dem rettet auch wenn es
Offensichtlich nicht an den betriebssystemen unten drunter liegt
Ja also
Kannst du das theoretisch auch überall anders drunter machen aber rettet hat sich eben im enterprise business umfasst
In deutschland war man eine zeit lang auch suze recht beliebt aber davon habe ich jetzt glücklicherweise lange nichts mehr gehört ich bin überhaupt kein fan von
von suze
Oder eben ubuntu ubuntu ist auch gerade die letzten jahre über und auch im auch im cloud umfeld und sowas beliebter als rettet würde ich sogar sagen
Und dann gibt es auch noch die
Letzten jahre über und auch im auch im cloud umfeld und sowas beliebter als rettet würde ich sogar sagen also
Ups falsches falsches falsches emote ich wollte eigentlich das hier benutzen
Ja gut bei sap wundert mich nix mehr die haben sich gesucht und gefunden wahrscheinlich
Ja
Okay
Chat wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache es ist zwar ist 11.40 aber ich muss noch mal aufs klo vorher
Ich gehe jetzt gleich was essen ich hab hunger
Ich hab ja nix groß gefuttert heute bin quasi aufgestanden und direkt an rechner
Aber
Ich mache jetzt freske genau
Ja, dann vielleicht bis später
Vielleicht vielleicht
Ist das alles gut zu